foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a casuals opening the show ever
I was just [ __ ] I almost ripped a
fart I thought we were off camera
God damn now I gotta pinch it the whole
[ __ ] show
I just mute uh holy but like let's
[ __ ] enough of this hey everybody
there's the show face
hey kids welcome to fat man beyond I'm
I'm Kevin Smith I am not Jason Muse I'm
Mark Bernard
hey holy crap man as you can see I'm
still trapped in time in my parents
basement in the 70s
Mark though got an upgrade I did look at
me this is all of Justice yeah meanwhile
at the Hall of Justice
um how are you my friend I'm I'm doing
well I'm doing well I'm uh I'm uh I'm
I'm busy but busy is good much rather be
busy than not the end of this year is no
uh no [ __ ] vacation I'll tell you
that you ain't kidding are you working
on a thing other than the thing I know
you're working on
um
yes
yes a couple other things
um
one of them is a comic book thing one of
them is a television thing
um but yeah man it's a it's the hustle
is on I'm gonna take a day off for
Christmas and I go back to work
wow uh me and Mark are working on a
thing
uh together
um a thing that we don't own but we're
working on
uh that is taking up the pretty much the
end of my year but sounds like Mark's
got something in addition to that
and I'm planning for the future and the
future may involve
um a halt of actions if you're a writer
um oh is that right is there a strike
coming
um there's a strike on the horizon we'll
see if it happens for what why are we
mad now
tell me why I'm angry
um I think the the bulk of it is over
streamers
and the lack of residuals the shortened
um episodic count the the it has gotten
harder I mean residuals is really the
big thing but it's kind of harder and
harder to make a living as a writer than
it ever has been before
um the money is good but it doesn't last
and it's harder to get the second and
third and the fourth job
used to be in the grand old days of
Television if you worked on [ __ ]
Magnum PI well hey she wants to hear
about
writing she's always wanted to be a
writer and I tell her it's a tough
[ __ ] racket it's I I'm not that I
don't believe you can't do it but it's
hard it's hard for a human let alone
someone with no thumbs to speak of so if
you listen to Mark he'll tell you he'll
tell you how [ __ ] difficult is tell
her Mark yeah I mean if you were if you
were on a network show then you worked
for 40 weeks out of the year you know
maybe 45 you know you had a couple of
weeks off maybe a month on Hiatus you
went back to work now I'm working a full
job is 20 weeks
um and that means that's another 32
weeks that I got to figure out what to
do to make my neck and it's harder to
get a second job in that year it's hard
to get a third job in that year
um and much of that is because of
streaming
see you lost her already yeah he's not
committed she's no commitment to the
arts
for a TV show about some [ __ ]
making a movie or TV shows I can do that
but I don't even have the patience for
the real real and then him pictures the
rear wheel and so what used to happen
was if you had a show if you wrote an
episode of [ __ ] Matlock you were
pretty much guaranteed that that episode
of Matlock would rerun remember reruns
when yeah the actual season and then it
was after that
um and then a show would tell them to
syndication and it'd be on the air and
every time it aired you get money for
that and that used to be how lots of
writers sort of made their in-between
times
which is hey I wrote an episode of
Friends look I got another check for
having written that episode of Friends
um with the streamers those residuals
are gone
um because that money used to come from
new advertising
um a license fee gets paid for an
episode the network sells adverse
advertisements against that license fee
and then you get a little tidy sum of
cash and that's gone
so there there are lots of grievances
that writers have the contract that the
writer's Guild of America beliefs and
West has with the studios expires I
believe in May and then we start
renegotiating
um and it could very well come to a head
because what writers want will be
expensive but at the end of the day I
think is necessary
um and it's always hard prying money
from Studios despite the fact that they
have lots of money
um you are uh one of those cats that uh
is always on that
um I'm like uh
all right whatever they give me I guess
is fine I never could continue to pay
like to be Oliver and be like please sir
can I have some more
uh what do we do do we strike do we
March
um you know the first thing is negotiate
see what that comes to if it's an
impasse then the guild will ask for
strike authorization vote
which is they ask the membership if if
this comes to pass would you strike
would you would you ratify the donut
strike and if that strike ratification
vote is in the high 90 percent
of of the membership then that is
another bargaining tool which is hey
guys we're going to go on strike you
don't want us to stop working because if
we stop working then you stop making
things
um and unless it's unscripted that was
that was what happened uh one of the
last times you went on strike
um was Hey look it's suddenly reality TV
is a thing that's happening because you
don't technically need writers for that
well though you're 100 writers for that
you just call them producers
um and so and the last writer strike
lasted about 100 days and that is not
good for anybody's business to shut
things down
uh somebody in chat Jeremiah Maxwell
said Warrior none just canceled they
canceled Warrior none as well I thought
that was doing well they did I mean the
first season did very well and then the
second season came with zero marketing
money behind it and so zero awareness
generated for it and then nobody watched
it
um everybody watching uh
Wednesday
everybody's watching Wednesday Thursday
Friday can you do the dance I am no man
I'm 51 years old I can't do that dance I
break like eight things I have not even
seen the dancing question my kid
um loves the wins Wednesday show she
loves the girl was Jenna Ortega she's
like oh that girl
apparently the world [ __ ] agrees
because a billion streams or something
like that yeah and I like that's part of
the issue is that you can never tell
what's going to be hit for Netflix
because they never they're they're not
transparent with their numbers so you
don't know who's watching what unless
they tell you
and then you never know who where
they're spending their marketing one
you know when is this writer strike that
I'm just honestly hearing about for the
first time when is it uh set to happen I
got a lot of writing jobs lined up this
year
um it wouldn't be you know I think the
contract is up in May there's always
chances for extensions there's only
chances it doesn't happen
um because I think everybody's beginning
to realize that streaming is not the the
font it's not the Fountain of gold that
everybody thought it was because you
spend a lot with no guarantee on making
a lot and they were measuring it in
subscriber and new subscribers to the
streaming services and there are a bunch
so many people who will subscribe to
stuff and so can you keep spending 200
million dollars on a show if you don't
get any subscribers for it
um and so now we're watching lots of
these streamers say Hey you know we're
adding ad supported models because now
we have to make money so hey Netflix who
said we would never have commercials is
about to have commercials everything old
is New Again
I remember when uh we were start when we
were podcasting for about a year this is
2007 me and Scott Moser doing some
podcast sound like an old man telling
the story
um
you know the the it wasn't even a year
we were six months in maybe and uh the
podcast had been successful and it's
because there's nothing else out there
you got to remember we predate you name
a podcast we beat it like we were there
first
um so except for
you know Adam Curry
arguably the father of podcasts and
Godfather of podcasting and Leo Laporte
who was in the space when I got here
with This Week in Tech
there's nobody else here so
um this podcast was pretty popular
and I was like oh podcasting is free
this is awesome and then uh Carol my
business manager was like here's a bill
for a thing called a server and it's
very hot and it was a lot of money I was
like what the [ __ ] is this this and she
said this is where your podcast is
everybody that downloads it hits your
stream it costs us money I was like I
thought podcasting was free she was like
for everybody else yes uh for the
podcaster apparently no
so or find a way to pay for it
I wasn't even thinking about making
money or turning into business I just
like podcasting and I didn't want to
have to pay for it and [ __ ]
so uh I I remember I said MOJ I was like
hey man like
we got a a [ __ ] letter an email
from Fleshlight because we referenced
them in Zach and Mary Mega porno and
they said if you ever want to do a Kevin
Smith flashlight we do one
I said I do want that I said but more
than that I would like if I'm to sponsor
our podcast is remember the way like
quiz show and that movie quiz show
Geritol sponsored 21. I was like can't
we get like a Geritol and he goes what
like a [ __ ] Pampers or a Wonder Bread
to sponsor our podcast out no like
flashlight maybe they'll do it and we
reached out to Flashlight and they were
like yeah okay we'll pay for it and
that was how we started doing ads uh
we'll be doing an ad in about 30 [ __ ]
seconds kids and it all started many
years ago with asking a a [ __ ] male
[ __ ] toy company
for a few bucks
so that I could speak my mind free
speech on the internet so
uh the point of that story
is rambling when I forget what it was I
knew there was a relevance somewhere
it's it's whatever is free is not free
for everybody yeah oh no I think my
point was
we all think like like I remember being
like Oh my God I'm I'm figuring this out
and we will get someone to pay for this
show and that's the [ __ ] TV model and
radio model going back to the beginning
of time like you know uh
that's right folks don't touch that dial
there's always
something that's selling the thing that
you want to see and for a while
with podcasts I was like oh well I'll
never that's not here but it is there it
was there as well we went right into the
same [ __ ] model that had preceded us
so many times
um I think was more of my point
everybody thinks they're creating
something new like you know Netflix are
like oh my God it's like a public
utility the font has been turned on and
it'll never be turned off because that
is what we're used to and life will
always be the same and Netflix is like
we're a futuristic [ __ ] company HBO
my ass we are the [ __ ] future We're
The Edge we're edging [ __ ] and
then eventually they too get to um
uh we're gonna do ads just like
everybody else the future is the past
kids we need your [ __ ] money their
business model was built on growth and
at some point you run out of people to
sell things to like they literally
expand into every country they could
expand into it's like and we've found it
there are X number of people who want it
and we're giving it to all of them so
now how do we make more money on top of
this when we had been designed to be a
shark just swimming and eating I guess
we got to sell some ads you guys welcome
to the RCA Columbia theater brought to
you by Patriot brand cigarettes yeah
it's the Tale As Old As Time Mark
sponsored by Disney
um let me tell you something about uh
you know I remember a couple months ago
in HBO Max is like we're killing this
we're killing that and everybody was
like this guy's nuts oh he's Satan on
Earth David's oslob and [ __ ] now it just
turns out everyone's doing the same
[ __ ] thing because they're he just he
just beat him there
uh all the streamers are like
this shit's too expensive kill that kill
that but you I mean the thing that
zazlov is doing which is a little bit
Insidious is that not just is he
canceling shows which everybody cancels
shows that's fine
it's canceling shows that have already
been produced like they just apparently
pulled the plug on season two of minks
um
um which was about a a it was like a
Playgirl magazine type thing with Jake
Johnson who is the publisher of a oh
wait yeah the HBO show I watched HBO
show what they're not doing the second
season they hit they were like seven and
a half episodes into their eight episode
order having shot at all and then they
killed the show and not only they
killing the show they're pulling it from
HBO Max so that they you can now no
longer see the show
but what you can't even watch season one
of menx no they're gonna pull it from
the service because the reason for that
kids is that they got to pay people for
that show
um
uh
uh it's not okay uh but zasla Joshua
Patton and chat says not okay because
oslov did that because of postmuge
attacks loophole they can only do once
if they never make money and it's true
yeah I mean he he just made a business
decision which of course it disappointed
a lot of us who are like oh man they're
just gonna make everything we ever want
from now on and that's what it looked
like at the beginning of the streaming
Wars it was like oh we got [ __ ]
Sandman the series like you know after
Decades of people like [ __ ] taking
runs at this and unable to do it there's
literally a season one of [ __ ] salmon
this was an era of dreams come true but
it looks like that era is coming to a
close and now fewer Dreams Are Gonna Be
dreamed or those dreams are going to be
brought to you by samanex yeah I mean
and honestly like a billion people
watched Wednesday
did a billion people sign up for Netflix
because of Wednesday or did the billion
people who had already subscribe to it
watch it because one of them is more
valuable to them than the other
um and that's that's part of the ongoing
issue of many of issues with the sort of
the place we are now in televised
entertainment
it's fraught
and evolving and it's going to be
painful until it figures itself out
and um
you know
um striking
is uh going to hopefully open up the
purse strings a little bit from the
places that that's always the hope it's
always the hope and it's figuring out a
way to return to a version of Television
that allows everybody to make more money
um including their Studios I think
they'll find
um Ophelia pain and chat goes why can't
we just go back to a channel on TV for
shows and not have to buy everything
because we we didn't want that anymore
no like we hated that thing yes we
wanted pretty new things we wanted to be
able to cut the cord remember that we
all hated the cord never noticed the
chord before until they started
streaming and then suddenly we're like
oh [ __ ]
and we all cut the cord and and that's
when everybody was like oh wait we could
charge them for every single Channel now
like remember you used to pay like 80
bucks a month to get all of this [ __ ]
and you cut the cord now you pay 9.99
for 10 services and now you're paying
more for the same thing you used to get
but no commercials have commercials but
hey you got squid games so [ __ ] you
sometimes you get a squid game
periodically get a stranger thing and
every once in a while it's a Wednesday
um my boy uh uh Ted biaselli from uh
Masters of the Universe Revelation and
the upcoming Revolution I've seen all
five animatics shows wonderful
um
he was involved with the show this was a
show I remember from the jump he was
like putting together a show
based on The Adams Family it's with the
guys who did Smallville
and I was like that'll never work no I
just [ __ ] say that I'm the guy that's
just like that sounds great it did sound
great and it turned out like then he was
like Tim Burton's doing them what the
[ __ ]
um but man oh man like that dude's
they gotta love him at Netflix right now
got the highest touch yeah man created a
billion views and stuff uh but I've not
seen the the dance every once in a while
I'm on Twitter and somebody's like just
shut up and do the dance I didn't know
that I was supposed to
dance monkey dance
um somebody said in chat that I'm
sweating I must be high as [ __ ] because
I'm sweating but I I swear all the time
which I guess is an admission that I'm
high as [ __ ] all the time
speaking of high as [ __ ] man
that's where you gotta get your dick
this holiday season high as [ __ ] kids
straight as a Christmas tree and fluffy
as well and how do you do that
well our first sponsor is going to help
you the good Folks at Blue chew are
gonna help you put your Christmas lights
up deck your Halls fill your stockings
and all that other [ __ ] uh the nights
are getting longer but the breeze isn't
the only thing that's getting stiff
that's right this episode is sponsored
by the good folks of blue chew guys we
all know that confidence can take you
far in life that's especially true in
the bedroom especially when it's time to
step up to the plate that's where
Bluetooth comes in
and I mean comes hard Bluetooth is
unique online services delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises uh the process is so
simple you sign up at bluetooth.com you
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
about like
how do I get it up uh no waiting in line
at the pharmacy
uh where all you'll be thinking about is
why won't it work Bluetooth tablets are
made in the USA and prepared and shipped
Direct
to your door like this is me thumbing
them direct at your door it's awkward
direct to your door in a discreet
package such as the one I have between
my legs Mark takeover so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform chew it and do it have
better sex and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try bleach you free
when you use our promo code Fatman at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code Fatman
you can receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information and as always we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring this podcast
let me tell you without the good folks
of blue chew we're not me and Mark
aren't doing [ __ ] we're sitting around
going boy we sure wish we could do a
show like I said sponsors
love together
that's the way fat man beyond is just
like Netflix we also need sponsors we're
all competing for the same ad dollar
somewhere some Netflix exec is like what
do you mean we lost blue chew to fat man
beyond God damn it
let me do we just we just made
somebody's [ __ ] end of you really
hard
as as blue she would have it
gg83 says no need to go to the North
Pole this Christmas use blue chew and
your pole will be facing north
okay hire that [ __ ] man
that's strong directional punnery that
is that's fantastic it's Christmas
Christmas is coming hard
um
all right chunk buckets that Chum Bucket
asked when are you gonna direct Kevin
James in a movie I think he would be
great in tusks that's a great idea I do
want to put Kevin James a movie I was so
regretted Jane sound Bob reboot not
begging Kevin James we'd even go to him
somebody could have shot I didn't need
to be there
um when a fist comes through the wall he
should have been [ __ ] knocker and he
just could have said his catchphrase
which I'm sure I've never seen it but I
imagine it's something like I'm the king
and then
you know [ __ ] writes itself
we should Mark up I'm your marker
exactly that's right Paul BART to the
rescue whatever
and then today would say snooch to the
booch or whatever the [ __ ] and we're out
credits
picture right there picture
uh let me tell you can I review a
picture that I saw please do
I keep wanting to call it meet the
fablemens I don't know why but it's just
the fablemens
have you seen this I have not Steven
Spielberg's in the picture well Mark I
happen to own a motion picture theater
smod Castle Cinemas where I'm sitting
above right now from the top of smodcast
Castle Cinemas that's where I'm
broadcasting from right now
um so I have access to movies all day
long that being said it's available on
home video and I watched it on iTunes
but we hooked it up to a screen
downstairs so it was just like the
Cinematic experience man
um what a [ __ ] picture this is I mean
we all knew from that trailer Steven
Spielberg doing his childhood his secret
origin why I am this guy this is a
Marvel movie it's literally the secret
origin of a [ __ ] superhero man
um a beautiful story of uh uh life and
family and how wonderful and messy it
all could be most profound like there's
a few of them a few lines that like
really hit home from from that movie
um but the one that like oh God it's in
the first 10 minutes maybe of the movie
and hit me so hard was
um
let me see you go the line is
it's easy to love it it's easy to love
something you have to take care of it
and I was like oh my God
I I work my whole life over I won't
write something
as beautiful or as
just perfectly [ __ ] succinct is that
um is that Tony cushion of magic
really was that's what I was thinking
man some of the [ __ ] you know it's
Spielberg's life story and like a lot of
some of them if you've listened to
Spielberg tell stories about his
childhood over the years it's like oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I heard the story oh [ __ ] and
they're all like dramatized versions and
stuff but yeah I got to imagine Tony
Kushner
guy who wrote angels in America probably
wrote The Line
you know you can't just love a thing you
got to take care of it uh let me find
the other lines that I [ __ ] loved I
was uh I was watching uh I was I was
perusing The Tick Tock as I'm now
wanting to do and I saw this sort of
clip of Spielberg in 2011 being
interviewed by Favreau and and Spielberg
was telling him a story from his
childhood by the time he met John Ford
when he was like nine or ten years old
and so they had put the footage from the
movie at the bottom of this thing so as
he's telling the story you're watching
the same exact stuff happen it literally
was now 10 years apart like the in comes
Jack Ford he's got you know kisses from
makeup all over his face and his
secretary goes in his office says you
got five minutes all right maybe one and
then she walks out with his Kleenex just
filled with red lipstick on it and like
as he's narrating it is what you're
seeing in that movie like he's the best
one of the absolute best scenes in the
movie it's the last scene of the movie
as a matter of fact is uh Young
Spielberg
finally gets on to uh you know the lot
so to speak he's been sending out all
these letters and guy at CBS is about to
do Hogan's Heroes
interviews with him about being an
assistant to an assistant to assist and
he goes but you know you don't want to
be in TV go as granny man it's [ __ ] Greg
grumberg plays the guy okay I was like
[ __ ] granny
um and he's like you don't want to be in
TV you want to make movies he's so you
know one of the greatest director the
greatest director ever lives right
across the hall
he takes him in there to John Ford's
office
and early in the movie of course young
Spielberg has gone to see like The Man
Who Shot Liberty Valance amongst other
John Ford movies and [ __ ] John Ford
has played fantastically by David Lynch
um and he comes in and
like you know it was kind of almost
quiet wordless performance but it's it
is it plays out I watched that clip as
well but I didn't see it with the clip
of the movie attached to it I just
remember that interview and I went and
looked it up and I saw it last yesterday
and I played it
um
the gist of it is is just so simple and
wonderful Spielberg is meeting a god of
Direction and Spielberg is you know they
might as well call this movie Malcolm
Gladwell the movie because it's all
about
his 10 000 hours to get to Jaws you know
what I'm saying to get to become one of
the greatest filmmakers ever and you see
that this kid started when he was but a
wee lad
[ __ ] four or five years old or
whatever
um there are many moments throughout the
movie if you're a creative person you
know particularly if you're a creative
person is like I fancy myself a director
that your heart will be cleaved entwined
by things that
seem to come out of your own life to
some degree but
the scene at the end you watch him grow
up he finally becomes like this young
man and God bless him he hired a short
actor
like that's the running like the gist of
this movie is a constant reminder of how
short Steven Spielberg is because the
guy he casts to play him is also kind of
short and at one point he moves to like
Northern California and he's surrounded
by these like you know Aryan Gods who
are all [ __ ] tall and [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] with him I had no idea that he
got like pushed around for [ __ ] being
Jewish and stuff like that
um but there's this uh
you know the end sequences him on the
lot meeting with [ __ ] John Fort and
John Ford's like David Lynch playing
like essentially David Lynch as John
Ford just like screaming his lines
and he's like what do you know about art
and he's just like uh he goes no go over
to that painting right there he goes
tell me what you see and he's like okay
there's two Cowboys on a horse he goes
no no where's the horizon
and he points and it's like it's up here
and he goes okay go to the other one go
to that other painting and he goes tell
me what you see and he starts describing
it again he goes no God damn it where's
the horizon
and Spielberg's like well I guess it's
it's down here
and he goes okay come back he comes back
to the desk and he goes when The
Horizon's on the bottom of the frame
it's interesting when The Horizon's on
the top of the frame it's interesting
when The Horizon's in the middle it's
boring as [ __ ]
now get the [ __ ] out of my office good
luck to you and that was it that's a
piece of advice so it's wonderful
wonderful little story and [ __ ] but this
is and I'm gonna spoil the end of the
movie kids but it's I got it because
it's so [ __ ] lovely that scene
happens and the boy man Spielberg the
young man leaves the building and you
know grabs the railing he's there it's
official he's he's made it
and he walks out down the lane in
between all of these sound stages
and he's heading straight toward the
Horizon which is in the middle of the
frame
and the frame
dramatically readjusts
to put the Horizon on the bottom of the
[ __ ] frame
it is
so beautiful that shot alone give the
man an Oscar
um it's I loved it to death and it's a
very personal story about him and his
his family particularly him and his mom
he entire relationship with his mom
um you can't just love something you
also have to take care of it
um you do what your heart says you have
to because you don't know anyone your
life not even me that's what his mom
says to him my mom was always the
opposite is always the opposite she's
like you know I you owe me your life I'm
like I know
um
uh we've come too far in our story to
actually say the end oh whole [ __ ]
movie is too heartbreakingly [ __ ]
beautiful
um
I hope they win a boatload of oscars uh
you know he's of course an amazing
filmmaker and always has been and stuff
but he's now at that place in his life
where
you know I've been reflective about who
the [ __ ] I am since the beginning
you know I I'm in the work this is he's
one of those Old Guard guys who he
observes doesn't absorb right he's an
artist
um you know it takes a while for those
cats to go deep you see their life in
their work like we've seen you know um
Spielberg always having
strong female role models like mothers
single mothers and stuff and that you
know it was always kind of woven from
his own experiences that but this
is a very confessional very personal
journey into like what makes him tick
and who he is and that's just something
that that generation of filmmakers
you know I I was way more Naval gazy I
came in going like existential me
those cats came in going let's entertain
and [ __ ] me I'm trying to make a picture
here and now he's uh old enough and and
you know comfortable enough and who the
[ __ ] he is where he's like you know what
would be fun I'm going to tell stories
about how the [ __ ] I got here
um I remember hearing an interview with
him I can't remember who it was with it
might have been
um the guy on inside the actor Studio
but it was a long-form televised
interview
and he was talking about the fact that
as you say like you know I didn't often
put myself in it but my stuff is in the
work like E.T under up until I guess
this point was maybe his most
autobiographical thing not that he ever
hung out with aliens but you know grew
up in a in a single mother household and
had a you know younger sister and older
brother and that that domestic world was
his domestic book but then the
interviewer is like well let's talk
about Close Encounters it's like well
let's
um and it's like I find it interesting
that like what did your father do it's
like your father was my father was a
computer program what did your mother do
my mother was a musician it's like and
so how do they talk to the aliens at the
end of this movie
it's like well they use computers to
generate music
and like you can see Spielberg had never
actually put that together before like
he never quite got that he synthesized
his mother and his father as a conduit
to speaking to somebody that nobody
could speak to because the math and
music math and music and he was like
holy [ __ ] like it's been there the whole
time it's like it's kind of always there
the whole time it's just wear your point
of the camera
um and this time it seems like he's
pointing the camera directly at himself
yeah it's good [ __ ] man there's a one
moment where he's a boy and he they take
him to see The Greatest Show on Earth
and like there's a train wreck in that
movie and you know they show a full
movie house that alone like made me
[ __ ] well up
a time when you know
movie theater going to the movies was a
[ __ ] huge event
and you couldn't find an empty seat and
the young boy is watching this train
wreck and you know it captures his
imagination
and they asked for a train set
and you know he tries to recreate the
crash and
and his mom's trying to figure out she's
like well he's trying to control it like
he's trying to control what makes him
scared
God it's so good and so she gets him a
camera
and she's like
you do it once
you make the train crash you do what you
need it to do
and you film it and then you can make it
then you can watch it over and over and
over and you could control it and so he
does he shoots it and then he takes his
mom into a closet oh God
it's it's hell if you're a filmmaker and
you watch this movie it's just like
takes your heart out it takes her in the
closet to show her this movie
and
it's like the crash over and over and
over from like a hundred different
angles and he's like I had to crash the
train more than once but I think it was
worth it nothing broke and [ __ ] and his
mom like loves it and right then and
there
you know all the [ __ ]
all this all the ingredients of the
gumbo are present to make the world's
greatest filmmaker he's [ __ ] starting
at age five six years old
most of us are you know [ __ ] picking
our noses and
[ __ ] like that this kid has a camera in
his hands when he's a child I'm like and
that's something that happens now like
[ __ ] crazy but you're talking about
the early 50s or some says [ __ ] like
that oh it's wonderful
um I yeah I is I think it might be
after clerks three uh my favorite film
of the year
um yeah I'm a big Kevin Smith fan so
there's no way that anything was beating
it's like that movie was made for me so
boy I love that movie um but yeah this
one is [ __ ] right there and
considering I couldn't Taylor make it
myself it feels as if it was tailor-made
uh for me beautiful experience it's so
worth everybody's time yeah I figured
maybe you know we'll see what the
schedule looks like but the next podcast
if it's next week which I think we we
might be contractually bound into next
week
um I might have my top 10 of the year
list by then
um and I will do my I will do my level
best to see Fable men's before we do
that cast so I can see if it'll make the
cut yeah oh it's a wonderful flick um I
watched it downstairs in theater one
that's hot Castle Cinemas where
on New Year's Eve kids what are you
doing for New Year's Eve come spend it
with me at my castle uh doing uh a New
Year's evening
with Kevin Smith ladies and gentlemen uh
ring in the new year with me it's mod
Castle Cinemas
there'll be booze
uh they'll be me and we'll be chit
chatting and then all of a sudden it
will be 2023.
um building the schedule for the
forthcoming six months of smodcast
Castle Cinemas just went through all the
new releases everything that's coming
out between
January and June
um and now we're gonna start laying in
all the events and uh
and programming I want to do would you
like to hear
would you like to leave me your home
phone number that's from Manhunter
uh I'm gonna tell you
what's going on sketch
where are you Kev okay here we go uh
Merry Marvel marching Society of course
a series of movies that made me such a
bunch of movies that were influential
and like what I became
Batman on Batman we're gonna be showing
Batman movies once a month nice watching
with
this guy
uh Brat Pack films of John Hughes Sure
Shot Mark as an s-h-o-r-e uh movies made
in New Jersey
uh rock out with your dock out the films
of Malcolm Ingram Rao Shaman the films
of Josh Rausch Ides of Mark
movies with Mark Bernardin
uh smodcast Castle Sunday morning mass
and hummus breakfast guess what that is
Clerk's open all night that's we show
all three clerks movies from midnight
till six in the morning then eat
breakfast catered by quick stop uh bear
is driving the clerk's cartoon Marathon
uh Silent Bob speaks talking over movies
commentary track screenings we've done
two of those so far enter the esque
universe the films of Kevin Smith
directly responsible filmmakers at
smodcast so like last week we had
terrifier one and terrifier 2 there and
Damian Leone and uh Steve Barton Uncle
creepy uh the producer he came they both
came with the cast and crew and we had a
[ __ ] packed house man it was
wonderful
um and then I interviewed them
afterwards we'll be doing the same thing
with the Russo Brothers in the first six
months of next year James Gunn Zack
Snyder's bringing Justice League
um Jason Reitman Jason Muse the other
directorial Jason he directed a movie
he's coming uh I'm gonna get Scott Moser
to come bring his Grinch movie he's a
director too
and we're gonna do an uh OG uh clerk
three script reading like the script
that we didn't shoot and stuff
um oh my God such good times man
excellent what are you gonna bring for
the odds of Mark oh I had a list I had a
list I I feel like we shouldn't keep it
a surprise
okay
no I'll play I'll play your game
Bernardin I'm all about surprises I mean
we'll we'll we'll we'll tip it I think
later closer to the date when we expect
people to buy tickets
but um but I think it's going to be
stuff that that does mean quite a bit to
me
um that I have never seen on the big
screen
um I know one
um
hell yeah my Street's a fire fit that's
pretty good L name and the Rockers
um somebody was like uh oh JL Ali bug
says we need more smodcast Castle
Cinemas across the world
you can get that in a streaming service
it sounds fun as [ __ ] no
streaming makes my job so much harder
I'll be honest
um yeah no we're uh it's experiential
with smart Castle man and uh we're gonna
try to make one work I'm not
some people have been like franchise and
I'm like we just started but I will say
this can I share something with you
please
um in uh you know Ashley is my partner
she's the math one and it's me and
Ashley and Jeff Swan and Ernie O'Donnell
um Tony uh who was the guy that reopened
the theater after the pandemic
uh so Ashley did the mat oh [ __ ] my
light went on Ashley did the math
mine kind of just blew out on me
there it goes
you there I'm here okay the uh she did
the math on uh which would call it
um our first two months we took over
uh September October
so in September October
we uh
wound up
there we go uh doing as much as the
theater did the whole previous year so
yes the key to that is just you know
grossly over charging for every picket
that's
that was my big fix I was like ten
dollars a ticket what if it was 75 and
no we've had a few cool events and [ __ ]
that have packed the people in and stuff
um but once again we're in a [ __ ]
when you own a movie theater you you
think you're in the Arts kids but really
you're just in the [ __ ] candy
business that's all so the concessions
uh have gone up considerably as well
um but the next you know course of
action Mark is to uh secure a liquor
license
like most movie theaters it'd be nice to
be able to serve booze uh for people who
like come in going like I would love to
[ __ ] just sit here and have a few
drinks and watch a movie and [ __ ] like
that so that's next in early 2023 that's
what we'll be
pursuing
smart Castle Cinemas kids come on out
it's good times oh my God
good times that means finding a bar
that's shutting down is willing to sell
you their liquor license because Jersey
unlike lots of other places has but so
many going around that's true you know
here we are talking about a [ __ ]
liquor license and [ __ ] bars and [ __ ]
and like neither of us have either of
those but we know a guy who does a bath
man jump on in here let's talk
hey kids
man himself how goes this coming villain
in Cantina sir uh last Saturday was our
busiest
non-may the fourth Saturday ever
it was crazy
uh and we're open for lunch on Saturdays
now but even that even if you just take
the hours that we were open uh they've
got it was La Comic-Con and they've got
that Empire strips back burlesque show
happening down the street
so we are the the
pre and post hangout for all of that so
it's uh it's been good it's been busy
I was explaining to some cats over here
about scumability they're like how is he
like
how come Disney hasn't and that was a
good because Disney don't own the words
scum or villainy or Cantina
yeah also
you know I've spent five years trying to
sell the fact that we are not a from a
particular franchise
um you know it's uh I like to say it's
like uh the Oasis from Ready Player One
you would if you were to build a bar in
the virtual reality world you would
start with a framework that feels
familiar and then you would add stuff to
it
uh to make it a reflection of all the
things you love not just a dogmatic
narrow banded little thing that you know
because ultimately like we want people
who don't like Star Wars to come as well
as people who like Star Wars you know
uh but yeah it's I mean it's fun
things are good my dream is that uh you
you bring a
scum and villainy to the East Coast
sticking up my smodcast Castle's ass
that would be amazing that's uh we could
probably make that we'll try to make
that happen at least you know a guy I I
know somebody who has a
space in New Jersey I know somebody who
knows a thing or two about running a bar
now so God you got your chocolate and my
peanut butter
uh so yeah all you have to do is ask me
you don't have to talk about it
uh yeah I think we can we can
we'll we'll talk we'll talk
we'll see
um
all right shall we hey did you see
fablemans yet
I have not I have not I I uh
I
I
have to be careful I've shot all The
Hollywood Reporter round tables
and there's a lot of really fun
look at him pulling his huge [ __ ] out he
got a shot oh uh if man when he's not
doing this and then not owning a [ __ ]
huge bar in Los Angeles right in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard and
[ __ ] he shoots all these Roundtable
videos that irritatingly pop up in your
feed all the time but yeah this talks to
this [ __ ] and [ __ ] like that JC's the
one that shoots it uh yeah yeah so
there's a lot
to say who you shoot but if anybody
watches them they know who you shoot
correct but we've only done writers so
far but I guess I'll tease that there's
a lot of fablemens coming up so there's
a lot of really good behind the scenes
stories about that I also
have to be careful uh on how I say this
I'm really curious to see it because
somebody who I live with
uh signed an NDA years ago and had been
working with a certain family
uh
to do a restaurant
and
uh
so they redid this restaurant that I
can't say the name of
um
but I got a lot of behind the scenes
stories while they were redoing that
restaurant as an homage to that person's
Mother after she passed so I have heard
a lot of those stories about a certain
family
kind of first hand
that I'm very interested to see how
they're dramatized
I feel how fans feel hopefully I don't
get sued yeah because I feel like that
was artfully done you you are so obscure
I forgot who the [ __ ] we were talking
about anyway it'll be fun to watch Meet
The Fan meet the fablements
did at one point used to be called meet
the Fable men's or something or is this
a Berenstein Bernstein Bears kind of
thing I think in your head you have to
meet the feebles then mating with
Peter Jackson movies in my end yeah I
went in looking for puppets and I was
like well maybe searing family drama
would have been better with puppets I'll
just say that
um wait you both saw Andor right I'm
still yes
but you you guys want to talk about a
lot of people in chat are like and or
and or I'm like and or what and they say
Andor oh yeah
it uh you know I I will I will defer to
the Star Wars expert uh currently on the
podcast with us
um I will just say
um it is it is one of the best TV shows
I've seen this year oh [ __ ] I'm not
surprised you're talking about
Tony Gilroy yeah like I mean never mind
the Star Wars of it all Tony Gilroy is a
bit [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] wrote
Michael Collins Clayton Clayton
[Laughter]
this is why I could never be a lawyer
the most dramatic moment of the case he
[ __ ] wrote Michael Collins Clayton
so the the hesitation over there I know
it's a c word I know it's a c word
Roman dies on College I appreciate that
um one of the greatest screenplays I
think ever written and [ __ ] so yeah and
then is the man responsible for [ __ ]
Darth Vader being villainous for the
first [ __ ] time like since he stepped
on an old man's suit on the ground and
[ __ ] with that ending of Rogue one like
he is is he finally copying to it
everybody [ __ ] finally knows he's the
guy that literally the guy that did that
part of the movie so it stands to reason
that Andor would be good
um to to some people some people like
don't seem to like it but you
some people you'll never please about
Star Wars [ __ ] man there's a lot of bile
out there but you're uh you I trust so
both of you I trust what was your take
on you just said it was one of the best
TV shows ever what about you bamf man I
feel like Andor was so good we as Star
Wars fans didn't deserve it like I
watched the whole show I
I how much I paid for Disney plus I
deserve it
deserve quality quality it was so good
it also uh it made like Darth spoilers
Darth Vader's not in it at all they
don't even reference Darth Vader but it
somehow made the Empire
more scary than if it was just like the
Darth Vader show like The Empire is more
scary in Andor than it is
in Rogue one or a New Hope or Empire
Strikes Back like it's
frightening how
brutal it is
um
I saw something I know people are like
it's slow it's boring I've had Big Star
Wars fans tell me they don't like it
because there's no myth in it like you
know Star Wars needs laser swords and
and spit and brown robed Wizards
um but man it's
I I think I'm stealing this from
somebody on Twitter but they said that
Andor is not
a show necessarily about Cassie and
Andor but it's a show about rebellion as
a whole and what Rebellion looks like
um and how it gets going uh and then
like I said it's like similar to the
movie traffic where you're like who's
the
main character in the movie traffic is
it Benicio del Toro Is It Michael
Douglas is it Catherine Zeta Jones and
it's just kind of like
the idea of drugs that's kind of what
Andor is for rebellion and it's just
it's got some of the best
um like speeches the characters give I
just it's
it's too good I'm terrified that it's
going to not get a second season
shooting it
um and I think that Tony Gilroy wouldn't
have signed on unless it's like if we're
doing this then we have to do it and you
have to want it and commit to it
um and uh yeah I mean it's he seems as a
Storyteller very interested in the in
the mundanity of rebellion be like where
did the money come from how do you how
do you support it economically how do
you how do you emotionally manipulate
people into doing a thing that's against
their what they think is their best
interest
you know the stone Skarsgard character
like his whole thing is we have to make
it awful for people to live under the
Empire we have to make it worse
otherwise they'll never rise up and so
how can we make it worse for them first
and that is like a long game that nobody
in Star Wars has ever been played before
um
and the Monmouth stuff as the as the
financier of the Rebellion it's just
it's heartbreaking the length to which
she will go
to see to it that the Rebellion has the
cash to keep operating you know and she
will mortgage her family she will
mortgage her friends she will sacrifice
everything to be that lady we then see
talk about you know many bathroom spies
dying to bring us his information
her [ __ ] family gets put on the Block
to bring us his information it's not
it's not
you know it's it's real for her in a way
that it's not theoretical
um and yeah there's it's it is just so
good it is it is the thing that I think
and yes listen Mandalorian there are
parts of that that I do love but that is
a Nostalgia exercise
um and the more nostalgic it gets you
know I think sometimes the less
effective it is
um
but this is the show that I kind of
expected that we would get in the
mandalorians place which is a reward for
people who are now in their 40s and 50s
who've grown up with Star Wars who now
want Star Wars to meet them at that
level whereas the Mandalorian is still a
kid's show and I've said time and time
again that is not a rock that is not a
pejorative there's nothing wrong with
the being a kid show I love kids shows
um but this is very much a complicated
dramatic exercise and I'm here for it
it uh
yeah it just it I think it lives better
also because we have the Mandalorian to
satisfy
the child part of Star Wars but in a
world where we get new Star Wars every
other month there's no reason why
somebody can't make a show that's
uh
emotionally complicated that you know
isn't just like this this guy's the good
guy this guy's the bad guy in baby
Yoda's cute
um
he's cute
um it's the banality of evil
speaking of the banality of evil kids uh
no joking matter space cosplay put up
this comment ready this is my life I'm
just sitting here doing a show
did I say anything remotely
controversial tonight kids so far okay
here you go no joking matter space
cosplay go find him if you want he's
commenting here in the YouTube thread
says when did you go from a good
director to a Hollywood sellout I I
don't know when that was because I've
never been a good director and I'm not a
Hollywood sellout otherwise I'd be
[ __ ] fabulously wealthy uh He-Man was
horrible get woke go broke
which is why we got a season two coming
next year
um should have let the heart attack do
its thing and go out on top
such a disgrace I would have went out
with yoga hosers was that Pete Kevin
Smith
did you love yoga hosers oh you piece of
[ __ ] you didn't like that either so if I
would have died when he wanted me to I
would not be going out on top
um how [ __ ] weird and wild that
somebody feels that way mark that
they're like you should have died
because then you wouldn't have made
He-Man
kids
uh let's find no joking matter space
cosplay
um and see what he's up to
see how full that his life is
anybody
isn't that [ __ ] crazy dude not for
nothing but like that is a hateful
[ __ ] sentiment there's one thing with
a bunch of people like stop crying on
the Internet it's like whatever that
[ __ ] make a a current reference piece
of [ __ ] but like that [ __ ] to be like
you should have died because your
opinion is different than mine and
that's my life every day that's one of
those things that makes you go like why
am I doing this why am I even on the
internet why am I on social media
um it's become a real like negative
Place lately and mind you I've been here
since the beginning
I've been online since you know you
could say like I did the internet last
night it was awesome and you did the
entire [ __ ] thing
but
who needs that
seriously
that's just some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
anybody know where he is
uh I banned him
a ban him let's track him down [ __ ] I
mean I kicked him out of chat
it
somebody's like you've been called worse
by better it doesn't matter just takes
the one to break the [ __ ] camel's
back man where you're like oh god I've
had it like I don't need that [ __ ] I
really don't need somebody to be like
you should have died from your heart
attack because get woke go broke it's
like and number one you got the [ __ ]
phrase wrong idiot
uh number two like
I wanna I wanna ruin your night now
let's find him
you know two could play at this game I
know I'm supposed to be better than all
this but I'm not so let's play
somebody wants to [ __ ] have a comment
let's I would like to comment on his
life or her but let's be honest
you know
we know it's guy
um everyone's saying [ __ ] that guy Kevin
yeah of course [ __ ] that guy but
so let's [ __ ] that guy
I'm not saying you know do something
horrible I just want to know who he is
he knows who I am
and can make personal comments I just
want to know who he is so I can make
personal comments
and then I'm like why am I doing this
what a shitty waste of time and that's
then I'm like well
and there's social media
I've answered my own question
maybe you'd set him a 52 year old man
but it's like
who needs this [ __ ]
seriously like there's some [ __ ]
rule book that I'm following like
I do whatever I want in this life
professionally
why am I holding myself accountable to
[ __ ] idiots like who are like you
should have died man because [ __ ] I
like what you did with me man
oh you trivial [ __ ] uh in any event
can we talk about something else I I
just wonder if he canceled his Netflix
subscription or no because Netflix is
actually who paid for everybody and did
he cancel Netflix or is he still is does
he still pay for Netflix because that's
that's the real measure like are you
willing to give up stranger things like
how how
how
strong do you actually feel this way you
know
it's just like
it's just you know
just get to a point where you're like
who the [ __ ] are you
like put your life up against mine balls
go ahead
[ __ ] like you should have died all
right let's see how productive your life
has been and whether it is warranted you
living
long tail what you got
it's unbelievable man like that I give a
person like that any amount of my
[ __ ] time
here we are still [ __ ] talking about
it
ugh
you know when I was younger they were
like you're [ __ ] fat
now I'm not and I'm like all right let's
find something else
[Laughter]
oh God these people have been around
since I was a child
that [ __ ] commenter uh not the same
one but my whole life man [ __ ] you
know
here's you want to know my villain my
super villain origin story mark
so I'm nine years old I recently
uh talked about this uh with a therapist
um I'm uh nine years old and I'm at uh
the Los Angeles at Los Angeles Jesus The
Long Branch uh Boardwalk
um then they got a peer uh Amusement
Pier it's got like a [ __ ] Haunted
Mansion on and [ __ ] games all that [ __ ]
they also have a giant slide
um and so Rose solo goes so does people
want does Kevin want people to tune out
Rose solo are you the person that's like
I wish you died of a heart attack if not
shut the [ __ ] up nobody's talking to you
Jesus Christ so in any event there I am
on the water slide having a blast
like you know I'm going up five six
[ __ ] times you go up to the top
there's some teenager goes wait go and
then you go and [ __ ] my God good
times shirtless
the last time I was ever publicly
shirtless in my life and here's why I
get to the top of the water slide
and the teenager whose job it is to stop
you and let you go
um goes oh oh hold on you can't go
pregnant ladies can't ride the water
slide
yeah
oh yeah jokes and I had nothing but
humiliation as the kids behind me like
ah
and I sadly slid down the [ __ ] water
slide
and I never went on a water slide again
and I've never taken my shirt off in
public I don't even take my shirt off
when I have sex
all because of something some teenagers
said when I was nine years old now that
moment in time also creates
that Kevin Smith because you know
[ __ ] I toughen up after that you know
some people like toughen up you cry on
the internet
kids
um that was uh me realizing I have to be
sharper and funnier that will never
happen to me again I will make fun of
myself before I ever let anybody else do
that and uh the long roads being me
begins so inarguably I mean I know there
are people who are like
but you know I've had an amazing [ __ ]
life way better than I deserve
way better than most cats will ever
[ __ ] know sadly and
you know ultimately
that [ __ ] making that comment
plays a big role
now
knowing what I know
having lived the life that I've LED
which has been so incredibly satisfying
creatively personally
oh The Adventures of Ghana
but knowing all that and knowing that
the price is that [ __ ] making
that comment when I'm nine years old
if I could go back in time
would I undo that
and take my chances living a normal life
that I don't wind up [ __ ] maybe I
don't get to do all these cool things
maybe I don't get to make movies
but I also am not vexed by you know this
comment so much so that it makes me
change the [ __ ]
shape of the universe to make up for
some [ __ ] that a kid said when I was
nine years old
thoughts
um
I remember having a conversation similar
to this
um on a TV show staff about a character
who had endured
awful abuse when she was younger but
that abuse then turned her ultimately
into a superhero
and would that person ever want
to willingly go through that abuse again
knowing who it turns them into and my
response was absolutely not
like nobody wants nobody would actively
Court Trump
you know and I don't I don't think that
if if that character had the chance to
do it all again she would sign up to do
it all again
um
and so like yeah we are the sum of the
roads we've traveled we are the the
accretion of our experiences and every
every step along the way has slowly
forged us into who we are today
um
and you know pain is The Crucible from
which we survive
and become something else on the other
side of it and yeah like I I I do not
have access to a memory like it but I
have memories like it
um and yeah I think
all of my decisions have led me to where
I am all of my responses have led me to
to become who I am and I don't think
there's a version of that that I would
change in any way
um
pain is necessary
and that's okay
but also I don't have to read the
comments
I'll say
the uh
my only thought on it is what's the net
right what's the net is it net positive
meaning uh have you and I mean I've seen
it over God the last decade plus of like
walking through a train station in
Manchester UK and you stopping to shake
every single person's hand to the point
that we're running to make our train or
you know
uh a hundred people who come into scum
and villainy every month who are like
you know oh can you do like I have
access to JC JC has access to Kevin can
you tell Kevin this thing or that thing
or this story or that story or the fan
mail we get at scum and villainy
you know every week like all of that
sort of stuff it's like is it worth
carrying the baggage for the last 40
years
how many lives do you change in the
right direction
even if you have to endure the
the crap to get and mind you the endure
the what I have to endure are harsh
comments like people there are people in
the world who have to endure
physical abuse or Worse to become who
they become for a net positive I'm not
saying like oh the price that I've
[ __ ] paid I mean [ __ ] in terms of
price it was it's been nothing that
being said it's like sometimes it just
piles up where you're like
Jesus like I you know I've loved the
internet since uh I've been on it since
like 1995 and [ __ ] but like
sometimes it's like man it's just a
conduit for people to be so [ __ ]
unnecessarily cruel and uh you know
somebody
in the in the midst of all this in the
chat duck nigoyan says uh oh no he says
hell yeah Kevin's life isn't that
positive action figure Academy goes this
is what his takeaway go he goes Kevin
makes love with his shirt on
I'm here to tell you that no I don't
make love with my shirt on because I
don't make love my friend I [ __ ] with my
shirt on
hard but with my shirt on and if it
slips up I pull it down all the time
I've been off Twitter now for almost a
month
and it's been wonderful
like
it's I at first I thought I was gonna
feel like a gaping hole in my life from
not like checking that feed every
morning and not reading replies and all
that stuff but
you know it it to your point was not
giving me very much
and and and taking more than it was it
was giving and even just taking time and
time ultimately is the thing that I got
back and some semblance of balance and
like yeah man it's this rule number one
on the internet don't read the [ __ ]
comments
well I gotta break that rule for this
one Technical and goes Kevin picards
during [ __ ] sessions is that pulling
your shirt down
[Laughter]
oh my God it was worth it just to get to
that I have never heard that reference
before picarding
why because he he I'm not a big star to
cut does he pull his shirt down like to
me that would be that would be um
spocking because remember when he gets
up after he [ __ ] you know takes the
thing puts online Star Trek too and he
fixes himself
he does it because whenever he would
stand up it was it went from maybe one
piece to a two-piece and then the shirt
would always kind of right up so then he
would just tug it down and then it
became this like authoritative gesture
of command and like it was always make
it so number one and he took the shirt
and then move on and so the idea that
you're making it so
you could call it everyone's like yeah
dude it's the Picard maneuver man
there's like this video
oh that's hysterical
Jordan Peters go Spock did it once it
was a habit for Picard every episode
once or twice
but card I've totally I've a card all
the time when I [ __ ] there you go and
somebody who's like he probably leaves
the Hat on I do
I stay on brand when I [ __ ] just in case
what if somebody comes in and I'm not
wearing the Hat they'll be so
disappointed
you'll be disappointed by a lot more
than just seeing the Hat seeing the the
[ __ ] they'll be like oh my God he
[ __ ] like he makes movies uh and that
depends on how you feel about my movies
and then give me a couple minutes
shorter
he went he went woken he's now
his dick is broke
um picarding oh my God that was so
[ __ ] worth the journey just to get
there
uh okay good times
where should we go now I can uh I did a
thing
uh what on Sunday
I was uh hired to shoot a q a with
Robert Downey Jr at the DGA
and Iron Man himself Iron Man uh Tom
Holland and Zendaya sat in front of me
uh Adrian Brody was there
and uh
uh Adrian how do they know each other I
don't know I don't know
uh but he was there
um amongst some other people I didn't
recognize and uh
uh he showed his movie senior about his
dad
oh the documentary about uh Robert
Downey Senior yeah very emotional uh
it's really really good uh it's really
interesting
to see
I mean you can see in because I don't
know if a lot of people know like his
dad was like a b movie like crazy
non-sequitur almost like reminds me of
like if Andy Kaufman was like
directing and Writing Movies it's just
like so wacky and bizarre
um but the movie is about
he he wants to make a movie on his dad
but his dad's like I'm not letting you
make a movie about me and he's like well
Dad then you can make a movie on you and
I'll make a movie about you making a
movie about you
um and it's fantastic uh but the best
part was watching
Robert watched the audience watch the
movie he made about his dad
uh was was awesome because he was like
crying and tearing up and smiling and
laughing in the back of the theater it
was really fun uh so I highly recommend
that highly recommend it's like 90
minutes easily easy to get in there uh
watch it
um it'll make you laugh it'll make you
feel some things
um
so you're highly recommending standing
next to Robert Downey Jr yeah yes yes if
you have an opportunity to stand next to
Tony Stark watch a movie I highly
recommend and sit behind Iron Man
correct senior senior
um I want to see it so badly I mean look
I'm a [ __ ] sucker for a documentary
about
a warm documentary about one's father
um but his dad directed a movie that
like I [ __ ] with throughout my entire
childhood um his dad directed putty
spoke but that's not the movie I [ __ ]
with throughout my entire childhood
um he directed um
up the academy
the Mad Magazine movie
the one that has a lot it had Jessica
Walters in it and Ron lieben was her
husband and he's like the army guy and
he's like uh ticket ass with a feather
and she's like what and he's a
particularly nice weather like you know
that was childhood classic
um post uh National Lampoon's Animal
House Mad Magazine was like we're gonna
[ __ ] produce a movie or you know
there's somebody approached Mad Magazine
putting their name on this movie and uh
there was even a statue of Alfred E
Newman there which they still have in
the DC warehouse and [ __ ] in Warner
Brothers Warehouse so yeah man I I knew
the dudes work intimately
um this I look forward to as a fan not
personally
um watching it with Robert Downey Jr
right there
would have been nice I wish she would
have invited me but uh I'm gonna say it
regardless it's on Netflix really good
really easy uh to watch the first oh is
that it's already available right now I
believe I believe it's out right now
um
and uh yeah if anybody if
it's an interesting look like if you've
ever lost somebody close to you it's
also an interesting look uh there's a
scene towards the end where he's talking
to his therapist about spoilers what he
thinks may be the last time he's going
to see his father
and you get like they just put it in uh
that session and they uh a lot of old
home movies of Robert Downey Jr as a kid
growing up
um it's pretty cool like it's pretty
cool also to
understand him better through
uh his what his father did uh they
address you know his father just being
like yeah do drugs with us when he was a
kid and some of that it's it's pretty
pretty crazy it's pretty good
um I'm gonna hook it up downstairs
watching the theater on the big screen
some of it's in black and white they did
some of it in black and white it's
pretty cool
um good for him he got to do it with his
you know make a flick about his dad with
his dad for his dad while his dad was
still here and
you know give them their flowers while
they're around kids not when they're
[ __ ] gone
um in the chat people keep asking me
about ww3 and I'm like
is this one of those like you know when
people are like hey man do you know
anything about the Illumina is this a q
Anon thing but I think they're talking
about Wonder Woman three yes which we
will get to which we can't get to we can
Dive Right In if you want
let's let's do it
welcome to news everybody yeah [ __ ] the
news is happening ladies and gentlemen
track down some [ __ ] news the show
just derailed for a minute there where
suddenly it was like come on be nice
and I forgot that I was on the internet
um
what's going on in the world of news uh
former news uh Hound Mark Bernardin
um well this week seems to have already
been the last the last like seven days
in the news cycle has been dominated by
conversations about DC specifically the
DC movies specifically what's happening
um what's going forward what's not under
the new James Gunn Peter Safran tenure
as the heads of DC Studios
um the first chunk of news that came out
was that Wonder Woman 3 was not going
forward and was considered dead in its
current Incarnation I which I found a
little surprising considering I know the
second one underwhelmed but came out
during the pandemic the first one made a
billion dollars first one did incredibly
well the second one
um I think even more than its Financial
issues was creatively not received
particularly well
um personally I was not a fan of ww84
um and I had moments but it wasn't as
you know the Wonder Woman was almost
pretty is pretty wonderful
superhero movie
um yeah 84.
as moments
it has it has a handful of moments
um specifically the magic box of it all
that's when for some reason if
like that that was where I bumped just I
was just talking to somebody about
Wonder Woman today and you know talking
about the relatability of DC characters
you know they're all born in tragedy a
lot of them are going into Batman born
in tragedy
Superman born in tragedy Wonder Woman
born of clay
and the person was like what are you
talking about it's like well she was
formed by Zeus himself and it's like
what do you mean like we're
she's actually hold on
um
talk for a second I'm live on I'm on the
internet
so uh yeah
it's right and again I'm not like this
ain't please don't write [ __ ]
articles Smith hates Wonder Woman that's
not true at all but you know I
I like I like that grounded
origin I mean I know you know look at
this guy is from outer space and this
planet blew up I was just super baby
isn't very grounded either but it's a
little more grounded than like
God took some clay and made Wonder Woman
as a baby it's like how do I sell that
like they blew over it so fast in the
[ __ ] movie remember because like hard
to sell exactly because I'm not alone
here
but I'm trying to be careful because the
internet will be like this crying [ __ ]
has such a [ __ ] problem with Wonder
Woman and I don't yeah I I quite liked
the first movie at least the first two
thirds of the first movie I think the
finale the last stretch gets a little
gets a little too DC Comics for me it
gets a little too dark and swirly
garbage rings in the sky and like what
what is happening here I didn't think we
were in Gotham I thought we were still
in the Wonder Woman
um I think the second film kind of
somehow makes it all about Wonder Woman
in unable a woman who didn't even know
who men were at the beginning of the
movie is now completely like [ __ ]
obsessed with Steve Trevor to the point
where she
kidnaps another dude's body and imbues
it with the spirit and the essence of
Steve Trevor all because she's dick
crazy and can't do without it I was like
this doesn't feel like the same
character that I saw before and I get
the characters evolved but this was not
this isn't some cool Evolution this is
some weird retro regression
um and then it just stopped making a ton
of sense after that and so I didn't I
didn't [ __ ] with Wonder Woman 84 that
much and so the the news that there
wouldn't be a 103 didn't somehow shock
me except for the fact that yes Gal
Gadot is your star and I think she is a
legit movie star and so maybe you'd want
to do that unless part of what James got
and Peter saffron are doing is wiping
the Slate clean is like you know what we
are we are not going to continue with
any iterations of these Heroes that
we're part of
um the previous run of the DC extended
Cinematic Universe whatever they're
calling so no Man of Steel two even
though Henry Cavill said I'll be back at
Superman
Aquaman 2 might be the last time we see
Jason Momoa as Arthur Curry
um who the hell knows what's happening
with The Flash movie
um except that all reports are that it's
great except troubled for all the
reasons why it's troubled because the
star seems to be in an interesting part
in their lives
let me ask this
um how is uh James gun fairing on the
internet Something tells me
people must have opinions and be blaming
him and and or is he in the midst of a
Maelstrom
um I mean he's he's he's responding
directly not to fans per se but to some
of the press stories about it which is
basically you guys don't know what we're
doing yet you're reporting what feels
like rumors and that's not entirely true
um and there have been a lot of kind of
back and forth and he said she says but
James Gunn has said look listen we're
figuring it out as we go
um there's not going to it's not going
to be a bloodless exercise like they're
we're going to have to sacrifice some
things that people love the Hope being
that it will lead towards a more
cohesive more engaging DC filmed
Enterprise in the future so we're in a
transitionary phase
he is uh him in the uh it was the other
guy Peter saffron Peter Safran yeah man
like that's
uh I I
don't envy having to do that job
somebody was like don't you want that
job I'm like God no [ __ ] no
you know I look forward to what they're
gonna do and stuff but like those poor
dudes have got to go through
get roasted I'm sure online over and
over again in order just to get to
their idea of what it's all going to
look like which will probably take a
year or two years minimum you know what
I'm saying and we live in the
information age where people are going
to speculate that just seems like an
impossible job
God bless James for like going like hey
I'm a filmmaker and I'm also going to do
this because right all the stuff I do in
addition to being a filmmaker is fun
that seems like you know
it would be fun creating a universe but
boy you're gonna they're gonna make you
pay for that fun
yeah I mean he he released a statement
because all the Wonder Woman stuff broke
in a Hollywood Reporter article then
Gunn responded to it like on the
internet
um and the statement was like Peter
saffron and I chose to Hound DC Studios
knowing we were coming into a fraction
environment both in the stories being
told and in the audience itself and
there would be an unavoidable
transitional period as we moved into
telling a cohesive story across film TV
animation and game but in the end the
drawbacks of that transitional period
were dwarfed by the creative
possibilities and the opportunity to
build upon what has worked in DC so far
and to have Rectify what has not we know
we are not going to make every single
person happy every step of the way but
we can promise everything we do is done
in the service of the story and the
service of the DC characters we know you
cherish and we have cherished our entire
lives as for more answers about the
future of the DCU I will sadly have to
ask you to wait we are giving these
characters in these stories the time and
attention they deserve and we ourselves
still have a lot more questions to ask
and answer
um so then the story came that Patty
Jenkins was the one who walked off of
Wonder Woman three now that the movie
was canceled is that she decided to
leave
um which she then rebutted herself by
saying no that's not right either
um and so she had to go on the internet
and clear up with a statement saying and
then tagging into Rogue Squadron the
Star Wars movie that she was on and then
left and then apparently is back on
again
she originally left broke Squadron after
a long and productive development period
when it became clear it couldn't happen
soon enough and I did not want to delay
Wonder Woman three me further when I did
lucasfilm asked me to consider coming
back to Rogue Squadron after Wonder
Woman 3 which I was honored to do so I
agree they made a deal with me in fact
I'm still on it and that project has
been an active development ever since
when we started hearing backlash about
Wonder Woman created not happening the
attractive clickbait false story was it
was me that killed it or walked away
started to spread that is not true I
never walked away I was open to
considering anything asked of me it was
my understanding that it was nothing I
could do to move anything forward at
this time BC is obviously buried in
changes they are having to make so we
understand these decisions are difficult
right now I do not want one has been a
beautiful Journey with Wonder Woman to
land on a negative note I have loved and
been so honored to be the person who got
to make these last two Wonder Woman
She's an incredible character I wish her
and her Legacy an amazing future head
with or without
yeah
you know I like Patty she's awesome
um Patty Jenkins
um but that I buy that right that sounds
legit I mean it I I buy it I think that
I think there's also a version of all of
this
which is still not quite the truth
because you know the truth
it can be elusive at times and the
things that people say in public are not
often the things that were said in
private
um I believe that all of it is true to a
degree I think there's still a lot of it
that we don't know
um Chris C and Chad said it's Kevin what
does active development mean
um that's a good question
um it means that
it ain't dead
and but it's not
quite alive yet either
it's a thing that's gestating
and that could take there's no
clock on that it's not like well you do
that for two months and then you're a
real live movie it's like active
development could go on for [ __ ] 10
years here we just you know clerks three
now available on Blu-ray and DVD and
stuff and home video of All Sorts
um was an active development for about a
decade before we finally made it that's
just to say that I was working on it the
whole time with a plan of making it so
it's not like an official
you know like you're in this category
and that's your tax designation it's
just some [ __ ] you say
um but it just means that they're
they're definitely considering it
Studios like yeah this is a thing we
might want to make if it reaches all the
ticks all the boxes eventually or enough
boxes for us to release hundreds of
millions of dollars right like active
development to my understanding is also
there's a person working on it at the
moment
you know there's like hey I want to make
a [ __ ] Robotech movie is there
anybody writing a robotic movie no but
the student wants to make one so they're
going to take meetings on it and they
have discussions about it they haven't
hired anybody to do it yet Stanley and
chat is asking so nothing's being built
yet nobody's making costumes or building
sets oh heavens no they are spending
minimal amounts of money on the creative
writing development and that's just of
the script they're Pro active
development doesn't even mean you've
cast a [ __ ] because there's
probably no final script to send out
here it's literally just a conversation
in a positive direction with a lot of
IFS if this works if we the script is
good if the budget is right if we get
this actor actors
then perhaps there will be a movie so no
they don't spend at what point do they
start building sets he asked
when the movie is green lit that's when
everybody is on board and they're like
we're going to release this amount of
money for them to make the movie This is
the agreed upon budget these are going
to be the cast members the stars and
whatnot this is what it all costs on
then and only then kids or Stanley
not the real Stanley but Stanley and
Chad
um do they start building sets and
[ __ ] designing buying costumes and
stuff
um he says just sending email
corresponds it's about ideas yeah or
being on the phone or zoom's probably
more in this day and age but that is
enough to consider active development it
means that it's a thing that might
happen there's a good chance there's a
chance I'm not going to say good there's
a chance this thing may become a movie
better chance
then you know an idea I have or an idea
you have right now because somewhere in
the world it's an active development as
Patty Jenkins is saying the Rogue
Squadron is an active development
so that means somebody's always been
working on it writing it perhaps she's
been given notes perhaps she's you know
I spin a lot of plates as well nothing
good and nothing anybody gives a [ __ ]
about but you know you try to keep as
many options open as possible
and it sounds like Patty was developing
a few things at once a director of her
magnitude and star power has many
options so it sounds like she was
developing keeping Rogue Squadron or
whatever [ __ ] going while she was
working on Wonder Woman 3 as well and
probably while working on something even
smaller because let's remember Patty's
responsible for Monster which is not a
big gigantic expensive movie you know
it's got some makeup effects but it's
kind of small so there's a good chance
that Patty is like doing these for them
and these for them and one that you know
she's doing for herself and she's got
them all in active development whichever
one gets closest to being made that's
what you lean toward that being said
it's not like they pay you for active
development maybe she got an overall
deal at a place if she's a writer on the
project she could be receiving money for
that but it's not a designation that
necessarily earns you money it's so far
what like sounds basic but what are
great questions because here we just
assume
everybody knows what we're talking about
but there are people out there that are
like when do they start spending money
on a movie and it's like as late in the
process as possible that's why it always
believes you as a creative to um this is
going to sound crude but there's an
expression called get them pregnant you
gotta get that studio pregnant the more
money they spend
you know the is this common wisdom that
if they spend they got to keep spending
that's not [ __ ] true at all as David
zazilov just proved you could finish
yeah you can finish a season of shows
and they're like oh no no we're done so
yeah it's it's uh those aren't bad
questions at all I saw some people
jumping I'm a man's dick for basic
questions but there's a time I didn't
know that [ __ ] totally and like there's
a filmmaker of Patty's
um magnitude probably gets paid a
certain amount of money to be an active
development on bro Squadron like she
signed a deal there it's it's like a
holding deal like it will pay you
something so that we know you're
committed to it because she's a rock
star director who's made a movie that
made a billion dollars so she's valuable
commodity as a creative and naturally if
she's got an agent worth their salt
they're going to be like well Patty
Jenkins you can't just [ __ ] expect
her to sit around she'd be making a
couple dozen Wonder Woman's you've got a
[ __ ] pay her to sit around and that's
that's what an agent does right see now
I am in active development and a couple
of things that I have not been paid for
um and won't get paid for until somebody
decides they actually want it
um but that is that is that is my Modern
Life not having made a billion dollar
movie
um I tried to minimize the amount of
free work that I do because it can
they'll take as much as they can get
from you without giving you anything for
it but
um for somebody like Patty like yes
she's been she's been paid something not
everything yet
um
all right so wait so that was one round
of DC stories what was the other wasn't
there long today which was about Robert
Pattinson and you know again part of the
the ever swirling Rumor Mill around what
exactly
um gun and saffron are doing is this
about how they might have had sex on the
Batmobile during production no
because I love that rumor I mean I know
it's old and the internet's like come on
that was years ago uh still whenever I
watch the Batman that's all I think
about I'm like
offset between shots there's [ __ ] on
that Batmobile
anyway what is it this is variety wrote
a piece that uh again sort of a state of
the DC uh Union
um that included this paragraph at least
one core element of the so-called
snyderverse is likely over a well-placed
source says that gun and saffron are
exploring the possibility of
incorporating Matt Reeves's iteration of
Batman with actor patent Robert
Pattinson into the wider universe
um so that if at some point they want to
make a Justice League movie then that
would be your Batman
um after the story was published uh Gunn
went on Twitter and tweeted a response
um there are a few reporters that I love
more than Adam very truly a good guy but
in this case he needs to get a new
source as this is entirely untrue
what so James shut it down yes
good for James or at the very least not
true yet
um the gun has fired
the gun is not trigger shy the gun is is
happily going on here and you know to a
certain degree I understand it you know
he's probably more accessible than he
needs to be
um but the same token he's the only one
who can can sort of
kill these rumors in their cribs to use
an awful barbaric metaphor
um but yes one of one of the one of the
the rumored
choices or paths that can go down is to
just eliminate the what had been the
Snyder verse is to just start over from
ground zero to completely recast
everybody that if Jason Momoa is going
to be in the DC Universe going forward
it'll be as Lobo not as Aquaman
um I mean I I'm all for that he [ __ ]
looks and sounds and feels like Lobo
yeah
yeah
do you imagine like only Ben Affleck
maybe not only Ben Affleck but like Ben
Affleck's the one that leaves to mind is
a guy who's like I was Daredevil and
that was Batman
and this guy could be the same in the
same universe
Aquaman and that was Lobo and then if he
pulls it off we'll all want Aquaman
versus Lobo
and then it's all the Momoa nothing but
Mamo all over our face necks and chests
of our Inception yes oh God I dream
about that
um so that is that is so far near as I
can tell it the totality of the rumor
Mills that are swirling
Chad is screaming at me that Chris Evans
did it as well don't forget he was in
Universe yes he was uh the Human Torch
and Captain America
he was indeed
it happened to the message what about uh
The Rock I heard there was a a Black
Adam story as well where they were like
hey man this movie's huge and it's
profitable and then somebody was like
that's not true at all yeah I mean there
seems to be a sort of ongoing
um
debate about whether or not Black Adam
is going to get a sequel or not and The
Rock has been doing his level best as
the the the engineer of Black Adam
to defend its performance and saying
like no we're going to be great we're
not going to lose money we'll be we'll
make 50 million dollars at the end of
its run
um once we factor in merch and ancillary
merchandise and all that stuff
whereas the box office analyst are like
this movie is going to lose money they
spent a lot on it he costs a lot
um it's it's now trending that it won't
clear the threshold that it would need
to to be profitable and uh and so it's
this weird kind of again perception war
going on including the rock invoking the
box office returns of Captain America
the First Avenger as some comparison
point he says we've already made more
than Captain America the First Avenger
and it's like oh sure
that's not necessarily a barometer of
much of anything because the Marvel
Universe
the reason why there is one is because
of fires not because of Captain America
and Iron Man did phenomenally well on a
third of the budget that they had spent
on Blackout
you know it made some 650 million
dollars worldwide on an 80 million
dollar budget
um whereas Black Adam cost about 200
million dollars and is only made at this
point like 375 380 million dollars
um and so
it much remains to be seen whether or
not there's a version of Black Adam 2 in
the new DC Universe that goes forward
whether there's going to be more Shazam
whether there's going to be you know
whether there's going to be more of
anything that we've got coming up in the
next like there's a Blue Beetle movie
coming in August I saw an ad for it I
saw like uh the poster yeah which looks
great is that gonna be a blue beetle too
who the hell knows
um all of that is Up For Debate and you
know gun and saffron and apparently some
meaning on the books to deliver
Enthusiast love the plan from where they
were going forward well you know what
black Adam's art
so it don't need a [ __ ] Sequel and
only movies with numbers and titles and
only hacks make movies with numbers in
the titles anyway that being said kids
clerks three now available on Blu-ray
and DVD there's a steel book at Best Buy
it's [ __ ] gorgeous wonderful couple
pair of documentaries on it if you're
looking for a Christmas gift for that
Kevin Smith fan the one you know left in
the world was alone at Christmas
uh you can go to you can get it signed
from Jane silent bob.com
uh and what are you doing for New Year's
Eve
oh [ __ ] are you anywhere near the East
Coast come to smod Castle Cinemas man
for a New Year's evening
with Kevin Smith tickets available at
smodcastlecinemas.com ring in 2023 with
me
back to you Mark um
hey can we talk about I mean I guess
we'll never figure out
well I guess math will figure out
whether Black Adam is profitable or not
people keep saying
uh Richard Greenberg said hey do clerk
three end up making money yes
very much so very much so so much so the
lions gates like what are you doing next
so
in any event
um
uh somebody keeps popping up a chat and
saying that uh Batman Beyond movie was
canceled I didn't even know it was
happening
um I think it was something they wanted
to spin out of both that girl which is
not happening and
um Michael Keaton's cameo in the flash
which also does not sound like it's
happening
they're taking that Batman completely
out of the flash that was the last rumor
that I heard was that they then shot a
Affleck
thing to replace it like I think they
didn't necessarily why are we going to
that Batman and not the Batman that
people know and so I think there was
some
there's a lot of moving pieces with the
cameos currently set for the Flash
movie because it seems to be setting up
a lot of stuff that may not actually
come to pass like Henry Cavill shot a
cameo like is there going to be more
Henry Cavill Superman I don't know
he seems to think so and he went on the
internet saying I'm back I'm going to be
Superman again but that is only because
he was in Black Adam and Man of Steel 2
is no longer on the Slate so what does
that mean
lots of things to influx
and meanwhile as the as uh as James uh
Gunn and Peter was saffron saffron build
their DC Universe
um Rob Patton says Batman is outside of
it but so is Todd Phillips Joker still
correct
like they're not they're not messing
with things that make them you know
seven 800 billion dollars they uh
released an image when because they
started shooting the movie right like I
saw that picture online Joaquin Phoenix
getting shaven shorn looking as thin as
a person can possibly look yeah that guy
looks thin and it looks like it was in
character photo like from the movie
itself no yeah
um so look I know you know Michael
Keaton got paid either way and stuff but
and I know you know there are some
people that are like we don't want old
Batman but I'll be honest with you I was
really looking forward to that seeing
that we put on the cape and Cal again
it reminds me of that story that Marlon
Wayans
um was initially cast as Robin in Batman
and Robin
and then it was a pair play deal and
then they decided to go a different way
so he still got paid to be robbing even
though he never put on the suit that
Beverly was shot
and paid like a lot of money to do so
um well
I'm I'm you know look whatever they make
over there I'm gonna watch regardless
and uh
sounds like they're getting ready to
make a few things
yeah I mean they're they're they are
still they're that place where every
Storyteller is at the very very
beginning they're in the blue sky what
could we do
if we could do anything what would we do
you know they're looking at all the
[ __ ] toys in the bin and being like
which one should we pull out which one
should we say for later which ones make
sense
you know and and Ghana said Superman is
a priority for us like we have to
[ __ ] figure out Superman
and whether that means
the townhouse coach GHA version of black
Superman whether that means the valzad
version of Superman whether that means
Man of Steel 2 or that means a
completely different iteration that we
don't even know that they're thinking
about
there's going to be a Superman movie in
the next five years because
you know it'd be like being Disney and
deciding that Mickey Mouse is not going
to be in anything
Cujo bite and chat says remember when
success didn't equivalate to money
not in this business no
yeah I mean yeah when it comes to comic
book movies you think they were ever
like well that was successful it didn't
make any money but we feel good about
ourselves
uh these cats they only let people grown
ass people dress up in capes and [ __ ]
because they're going to make billion
dollars and if they don't
they don't consider it
successful but as long as there's been a
movie business uh success is always
been
uh equal to money for those that run the
business no yeah I mean it's what used
to exist in like the 70s 80s 90s was a
longer tale of when things got to make
money yeah no more windows that you
could make money during like a
theatrical release was not the only time
you'd make money in fact it was not even
like the biggest time you'd make money
you know so there are movies like
Princess Bride that were box office
failures that eventually became beloved
you know movies and also incredibly
profitable because you could sell VHS
after VHS after the LaserDisc after DVD
you could press it eight different times
and put new [ __ ] in it and keep charging
an audience for it
um that market doesn't exist anymore so
the only way you get to make a movie
good bad or indifferent is we have to
Spanish a ton of money on making sure
men look great and then we have to make
four times that back in the box office
or it was a failure even if it's great
it was a failure and we won't be making
another
it's always about money it's just now
that money has to come up front
there's no there's no waiting for a
thing to find its audience
um they know that right away
Stan Lee and chat is like remember 100
million dollars was successful I do yeah
like when a movie if a movie made 100
million dollars you're like oh my God
like
that was my barometer for Success
forever Pulp Fiction did 100 million
dollars
yeah and it was like oh my God like a
movie that original could make 100
million but now the magic number is a
billion make 100 million people like huh
good on you yeah I'm gonna make another
impressed people in this business I mean
it used to be I remember that like I
think it was Denzel who was making 20
million dollars a movie because he would
guarantee you a 20 million dollar
opening weekend and that made sense
because you know you're spending 40
million on your movie if you make 100
year in profit everybody wins
um but that those numbers just don't
work anymore
I mean when everything everywhere all at
once makes 100 million dollars that's
100 a hit because that movie costs 10.
um
Braden Gustin in chat rights Pulp
Fiction sold 100 million dorm room
posters he's [ __ ] right about that
oh yeah
so any of that money
how much did uh
[ __ ] uh Black Adam make
um well you can we can check it right
now
where are we Black Adam
[Music]
I mean I own a movie theater and I
[ __ ] I said it when it came out and I
ain't talking
[ __ ] but like it was the number one
movie that week but on a Friday night we
had like 12 people
but now that's not just Black Adam
that's like hey that's our movie theater
and B that's the state of movie
exhibition in general but what we're
trying to do it here it's mod Castle
Cinemas is enough interesting things
Mark so that when you're just like
looking for a regular ass movie
you look for us as opposed to one of the
other multiplexes in the area and stuff
so bit by bit we'll continue to build
our reputation after every event we do I
love on Twitter I see people going like
I see what you're doing there I see it I
like it like it's it's good Black Adam
is made worldwide 389 million dollars
you know
it's just unfathomable now all right cut
that in half because that's what the
studio walks with so
150 190 million
is going back 190 to 200 million is
going back to Warner Brothers what was
the budget of this [ __ ]
um it uh it is not publicly known but it
is definitely upwards of 200 million
dollars
um
plus another 200 million dollars in
advertisements
um
yeah
wow
which you know it's part of the the
conventional wisdom has always been that
a movie of that size a blockbuster needs
to make three times its budget back
before it hits profit
you know and so if you're moving costs
200 million dollars you need to make six
and at this point they're at 390.
yeah they're they're not even a break
even yeah because the rock also takes a
big chunk of that money off the top
you know and also I don't know how they
factor in in ciliaries like [ __ ]
merchandise and [ __ ] like that but I
haven't seen a [ __ ] ton of Black Adam
action figures and t-shirts so I don't
know
I'm sure they're making money there but
and I don't know if it factors into
their overall this is where the movie
map gets even more specious kids like
movie math on a basic level if you make
just a movie where people talk to each
other
is an elusive art form because it's
meant to hide money from the filmmakers
from from you know [ __ ] everybody uh
from the government so it's tough to say
what they consider
like maybe when the rock said all that
he was like you know I was including
marketing I was including all the
merchandise as well but
I I don't know what kind of merchandise
and they've done thus far on Black Adam
I'll tell you you know who's [ __ ]
filthy rich and will never have to work
again is whoever [ __ ] came up with
that t-shirt that's on Stranger Things
bro I live on a con circuit now right
you know I went to a lot of Fan Expo
shows I went to Galaxy Con in Columbus
I I wish I had a [ __ ] book
[ __ ] it a dime
for everybody wearing that shirt man
whoa
oh I'd be rich that's a [ __ ] shirt
that penetrates right there this is the
number one selling shirt of the year
they said
Hellfire clip we're doing it wrong we
need to come up with a cool shirt we
have a shirt of our own man go to
jamestown.com and get our Jeff's Kiss
shirt yeah we're selling [ __ ] yeah look
at that [ __ ] right there don't you want
that on your face neck and chest make
that the number one shirt stranger
things has enough give us just a we just
want to wet our beaks a little with just
a little bit of that filthy t-shirt
money man
so maybe we could work a little less
hard
write five less shows [ __ ]
uh going across the aisle there is some
uh some Marvel news very small but I
found it kind of interesting
um especially on the heels of the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
which did you watch that which was
absolutely lovely I um I thought the
first half I was like oh it's cute
second half James landed it very
emotionally and I was like that was well
worth the journey
um you know spoilers having yondu back
in any way shape or form even in
flashback form was
key to it and that was pretty powerful
man you know I'm gonna be obviously I'm
a Rooker fan going way back but that was
really nice the whole thing was [ __ ]
nice more of that man more like give me
a [ __ ] half hour 45 minute thing
don't have to be a [ __ ] movie just a
side adventure with some of my favorite
characters but yeah nice thing that
they're gonna get because the next time
we see them sounds like it's gonna be
the last time based on that trailer that
trailer is wonderful the Guardians 3
trailer but the one that I saw at
Comic-Con even better yeah
um way better had had the do you realize
that song as the whole [ __ ] running
track it was so [ __ ] beautiful I
don't know if they'll release that ever
but the one that everyone has seen is is
really good but the one I Comic-Con was
pure perfection bam fan you had
something to say I was just gonna say I
felt like there's a giant missed
opportunity where Drax is drinking at a
bar off of Hollywood Boulevard missed
very big opportunity missed there
saw that as I saw them like Hollywood
Boulevard [ __ ] a couple blocks from
my house and I was like didn't shut up a
Marvel movie I was this close I could
have went down there I could have hung
out in front you know a [ __ ] the
groman's Chinese Theater wearing my
Silent Bob outfit taking pictures of
people for 10 bucks a shot man like
[ __ ] then I could have wormed my way
into the Marvel Universe to the back
door people like oh do you see that
Silent Bob cosplayer and the cosplayer
that is let's try to back door into a
Marvel movie [ __ ] dumbass dick he's
always crying on the internet
um let's see my internal monologue
don't read your own
I know why
the uh I've thought of you though I
watched that I was like oh they should
have [ __ ] went to Banff Man's Bar
what is that yes coming villain
located in on Hollywood Boulevard in
Hollywood California kids
but yes it seems that prompted by the uh
the holiday special for Guardians Ryan
Reynolds
um during an interview was like yeah you
know in 2016 2018 whenever he and Rhett
Reese and Paul wernick who all wrote
Deadpool in the sequel and then on
Deadpool three
um they wrote a script for a Christmas
movie featuring dip
um and that screenplay was never
produced
um the Reynolds quote is I would love to
see a song and dance number in a
Deadpool movie four years ago Rhett and
Paul and I wrote a Christmas movie
starring Deadpool but I got lost on the
shuffle of Disney acquiring Fox and
never got made maybe one day we'll get
to make that movie it's not a musical
but it's a full Deadpool Christmas movie
so one day
and like yo
that seems like a no-brainer yeah yeah
I'll see that you can have my money for
that I'll give you my money and his
money if you make that yeah I will take
his money and I'll give it to you
you can show me that
um hey somebody asked in chat uh they
want you to talk about uh del Toro's
Pinocchio did you see it I did see it
um and it's funny because I was I was
talking to to you about this a little
bit earlier that like this stop motion
is so good
that after a while you stop noticing
that it stop motion like this spell
works and so it just suddenly looks like
reality
and then the other weird thing happens
which is then it becomes a little less
impressive because you don't know to
think about the fact that that's just a
puppet that somebody moved fractions of
an inch
for years on end to make that scene work
like it's it's the weirdness of it and
like when the magic Works does it then
somehow become a little less impressive
um and that's an open question I have an
answer for it but like you know the the
I don't need to know that how they made
the muppets ride motorcycles and the
Muppets Take Manhattan I mean bicycles
um it's super impressive how they did it
but 12 year old me just thought it's
cool that Muppets are riding [ __ ]
bikes
um
and so like it's not it's not the it's
not the Pinocchio story that I'm
familiar with in that like yes they're
such a pedo yes there's a whale but it's
very much you know Del Toro movie it's
very much about sort of circus Freaks
and monsters and Fascism and you know
it's all taking place during you know
what seems like the run up to where in
the inclusion of World War II maybe one
I don't know but there's bombers and and
like child soldiers and
it's uh and lots of death you know the
Pinocchio as a wooden boy dying a bunch
of different times
um it's uh it's it's gorgeous and it's
dark
the songs aren't great
um but I also don't know that they have
to be there's only a couple of them
they're fine
um but no it's well worth a watch it's
it's 90 minutes long
um that'd be pedantic for a moment
please do Jake Thomas in chat said uh
well clay Harrison said Kermit had legs
what the [ __ ] in reference to your
Muppets riding a bike Jake Thomas then
said they rode motorcycles in Emmett
otter was it motorcycles or was it
schemobiles
like I remember there was a wrong room
but I thought they were all in the snow
and [ __ ] like that I lost you for a
second there wasn't motorcycles in them
and honor he's saying uh they rode
motorcycles in Emmett otter but I'm like
did they rode ride motorcycles or was it
like a ski like a
what are those things that you ride on
that are
ski snowmobiles snowmobile that's it my
imagination they were snowmobiles
because that took place during the
winter Emma daughter's jug ban Christmas
yeah I thought like the bad guys did
ride motorcycles I thought that it was
it was all like it was a biker gang
ultimately right that that's my memory
of it but it's been it's no uh Nick
Nicholas Hamill says I literally just
watched the other day it's snowmobiles
you know thank God
because I was sitting there going like
have I been
is that Mandela effect my whole life I'm
like no they were on snowmobiles and
everyone's like no they were on
motorcycles is that the Berenstein Bears
all over the second time this evening
it's playing downstairs in my movie
theater then you I mean apparently
everything yeah releases Netflix stuck
in a theater as well we didn't get Glass
Onion [ __ ]
I saw the glass on you I did you like it
it's
great
yeah I have nerve from a single person
that and it's like it blows everyone
yeah oh they [ __ ] they punted it
man it's [ __ ] mid Ryan Ryan
Brian Johnson mid ride Johnson somebody
[ __ ] yelled at me when I put up that
picture of me crying about what kind of
forever gone like how the [ __ ] could you
cry that hard at Mid marble
and then recently I guess Kevin feige
described quantumania's Peak Marvel or
something and a bunch of people are like
we'll see
nothing though is going to compare to
[ __ ] learning the term picarding
recording it's a beautiful thing and
then there's rikering as well what is
recording rikering is uh because when
you go number two but number one number
two it's a it's the actor Jonathan
Frakes whenever he would sit down
he would never sit down like a normal
ass person he would always like kick a
leg over the top of the [ __ ] chair
and then sit backwards on it like and
and it's every time he's sitting every
time he's in the ready room with Picard
every time there's a chair that has a
[ __ ] back you could move he's sitting
on it backwards and kicking a leg over
it so rikering in Bacardi two guys who
were on apparently unwilling to use
things the way they were meant to be
used
that's but that's true acting is a true
acting is making a choice and those are
two choices that help Define those
characters so much so that everybody
noticed absolutely and there there is a
compilation of clips of the Picard
maneuver where he'll tug the shirt but
then his a little Insignia com badge
will pop off
because it wasn't like pinned on it's
just like a little Velcro Tab and so
just
uh cross men Jeff and chat says Pooh
bearing or Donald ducking shirt with no
pants that I've heard of course I've
been Donald ducking it that's how I [ __ ]
I Donald Duck at hardcore I
I Winnie the Pooh it hardcore but I've
never until tonight heard the term
picarding
beautiful thing
so [ __ ] here for it um
uh folks asked about have we seen the
spider-verse trailer
yes I did and I'll be honest with you
it's [ __ ] mid-spiders
getting mid bro only this generation the
internet
I'm up with like
like a withering term like mid and it's
like I'm my whole career's been mid I
don't know why this is suddenly a
[ __ ] negative term mid is where I
live [ __ ] but in any event for me this
looks like Peak uh spider-verse although
I don't know what the [ __ ] going on
why is Spider-Man 2099 going after our
kids do you think it's because in the
future they you know become bad or they
have a kid that becomes Hitler or some
says [ __ ] who [ __ ] knows but it was
beautiful [ __ ] trailer you know the
voice over from his mom with all the
[ __ ] butts from the previous movie
including the one shot that makes Mark
Bernard and cry the only thing in life
that makes hard-ass Mark Bernard and cry
is is [ __ ] miles yeah breaking that
glass oh [ __ ] yeah
broke my heart in Twain and it does the
thing that that I'm also a sucker for
and I think I believe you are as well
which is
voice over from a parent talking about
their kid being used in a different
context
um so it's it's it's Jarrell talking
about color like they will join you in
the sun clock you just have to show them
the way they will stumble first but you
can live all of that [ __ ] and be like
wow you're special I see a spark in you
you just gotta you just gotta believe
like all of that [ __ ] just is is playing
the violins for me and so Hmong
talking about that is is yeah I'm here
for it play Harrison and Chacos dude we
grew up with Nicholas Hammond playing
Spider-Man and No villains the kids with
mid [ __ ]
it's true so spoiled man it's like we
had a time when it was like we had a
Spider-Man on the electric company even
he fought people like [ __ ] bad
grammar and [ __ ] yeah I just got to get
this picture this picture [ __ ] is really
hard man
um
what else we got yeah I thought was
absolutely wonderful but I mean [ __ ]
come on that that movie is absolute
[ __ ] Bliss you know and God damn them
for sneaking in a Stanley shot as well
it's like you you [ __ ] like
they they really went and pulled every
damn heartstring cannot wait
um
last new story
um is a video game related Nick Story oh
it's about the God of War video game
which have you played the God of War
Games Kevin I have not but Jordan
Peterson chat goes mid parent voiceovers
a [ __ ] men what's wrong with these
joyless kids man
there's high and there's low and that's
it there ain't no mid there is a central
Jersey though I am from it yes and there
is a Mid-Atlantic yeah so they say so
they say
um yeah the the witheringness of of
average is a is only a thing that this
generation could invent
mid
what's wrong with being average being
average can be exceptional if you take
an average life and somehow make it like
showy and put it on a pedestal I'm
living proof of that
I made a success you want to be me
because you're happy at the mid never
mind these lofty goals of [ __ ]
achievement you get to the mid and you
just stay
if everyone is exceptional nobody is
exactly
the same way speaking of exceptional uh
do you watch Rick and Morty no [ __ ]
opening of this current little season
drop that they did is one of us met a
wonderful episodes about writing
it's it's so it's such a writer's
episode it was absolute Bliss uh what
about you there Beth man you got
something to share I just wanted to say
gnome Saiyan in chat goes Bluetooth
because [ __ ] mid
[Laughter]
truly
it's truly uh true truly you can truly
your way
to hardness with uh moochu but we also
have another sponsor I guess we should
well we'll hit them before q a gotcha
what else yes God of War yes uh the the
it's there have been seven games in the
God of War series but the the most
recent two god of war and God of War
Ragnarok are phenomenon
um I've played them both they're
absolute Majestic games
um and it's very much a story about a
father and a son which is part of what
gets me
um it's about a felon in Kratos the god
of war who after exiling himself from
his blood soaked past in ancient Greece
hangs up his weapons forever in the
Norse realm of midgard but when his wife
dies he sets off in a dangerous Journey
with his estranged son to spread her
arches on the highest peak his wife's
final wish krato soon learns that the
journey is an Epic Quest and disguise
one which will test the bonds between
Father and Son and force Kratos to
battle New Gods and Monsters for the
fear of the world
um that sounds a little whatever but it
is so much about a father trying to bond
with his son and he doesn't really know
and it's called what god of war and it's
a father-son story yeah yeah and that
and the kicker at the end of the the
first game again it's all about sort of
North mythology and you know the the
father's name is Kratos his son's name
is atreus but then they reveal at the
end of game number one that his Norse
name is Loki and he's the son of a giant
and so the character we've been falling
in love with is the [ __ ] god of
mischief and by the time you get to the
second game the prophecy is that Loki is
integral to the the on the the onslaught
of dragon and so can you fight against
your fate can you set your own path in
life and then what happens when your
child
um does the thing that children do which
is growing up and trying to maintain
some of their own agency and trying to
regain their own control over their
lives
um it is actually a very sort of Deep
kind of
synthesis Mythos of what it is to be a
dad and what it is to be a son and what
it is to allow space for a kid to grow
and change and let them make mistakes
even if those mistakes might bring on
the end of the world
um Amazon Prime Video has ordered a
series of God of War
um it is written by the at least the
pilot at the very least is written by
Mark Fergus and Hank Osby
who did Iron Man the first Iron Man and
Children of Men
with a fellow named Rafe Judkins who did
The Wheel of Time as the showroom
um I couldn't be more excited for this
only because I love the [ __ ] TV show
I mean I love the game and Amazon is the
only place at this point which will
spend the money to do this right
um Amazon seems to be the John Hammond
of of TV Outlets which is the Google
spare no expense excellent reference
Matt how much do you need for Lord of
the Rings spend it how much do you need
spending
um so yes that that is our last news
story a a wonderful game coming to the
screen
um hopefully a trend that will be
continued
um you know last of us is coming in in
January God of War who the hell knows
when but there's been a raft of
wonderful story Central games that are
getting their their chance to shine in a
different medium and I'm here for it
um so that HBO show the one uh what is
the rest of us Last of Us yeah that's
still happening that wasn't killed by
that was not killed because that's just
on HBO HBO that's not an HBO Max and
they are still invested in HBO HBO
Kratos is Jeff's kiss says uh Wicked
Nemesis thanks wonky Kong says God of
mid
Nicholas Hamil says just watch people
play it you will cry it's an amazing
story is he right Mark it's amazing he's
not he's not lying whatsoever will I cry
you will cry
is that really a fair barometer anymore
I mean I'm not sure but
I heard the term picarding [ __ ] move
um uh if [ __ ] in chat says uh rest in
peace uh battlemente yeah Angelo
badalamente who did the score of course
for many things but uh Twin Peaks leaps
to mind passed away
David which is a pretty good
collaborator yes uh Brooke is very very
sad man
um how old anybody
no
hold
85.
I was gonna say did we really shut down
for that I'm so sorry 85. anybody know
anybody know what we'll find out 85
years old what an amazing life
um
so what else we got I guess we got a
straight story Mulholland Drive
has a lot of [ __ ] David Lynch that's
a lot of Lynch uh a clean game pointed
out that uh Irene Cara passed away since
the last time we did a show
um you know she was a the radio voice of
my childhood boy that voice was a happy
childhood
um she also did Fame
I'm gonna live forever
um and she will because of the music
that uh she sang and I'm sure we could
do an hour on how haunting that [ __ ]
[ __ ] scene is in Fame even as a kid
it was like
business is like they're gonna have to
see my boobs one day just like that boy
on the [ __ ]
water slide the answer is yes
she was uh an incredible Talent
um sad to see her go man indeed
uh she's I did a playlist a hundred
songs from 100 movies that plays
whenever you're at spod Castle Cinemas
located in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
Jewel of the Jersey Shore come for New
Year's Eve a New Year's evening with
Kevin Smith tickets available it's
mycastlecinemas.com in any event I put
together like a playlist that runs and I
talk in between each song and she's got
like three songs on it I think
uh so
um okay uh agent o o Saul said Fame is
such a dark movie you are not kidding
man
I can't speak to remake but the Alan
Parker one [ __ ] man it does it [ __ ]
it's a it's a
it ain't no hard it ain't no easy walk
man Fame costs right here is where you
start paying with disturbing scenes like
that [ __ ] one with Coco
um okay we got uh another sponsor my
friend we do indeed because I assume
there's only one person watching the
show uh friends kids
second half of this show the one that
gets us into the Q a part because God
damn what a long show uh is sponsored by
our friends native are you kidding me
native makes you smile unbelievably
[ __ ] good man when it comes to
personal hygiene who has the time to
read that long list of ingredients on
the back of a bottle some ingredients I
can't even pronounce men if you're like
me and you care about what goes on your
body it's time to try native personal
care products like I did and have every
native product is thoughtfully
formulated to keep you feeling and
smelling fresh
all day long man uh while we're talking
about a kid smell and feel fresh all day
long with Native get 20 off your first
order by going to nativedeo.com
Fatman right now I'll wait
or use the promo code Fatman to check
out that's
nativedeo.com Fatman uh or use the promo
code Fatman at checkout for 20 off your
first order man native has been here for
us since the beginning uh and they've
been there for you they're making stuff
you can put on your body man think about
the [ __ ] you put on your body all the
chemicals and whatnot native so you know
what we're gonna go aluminum free for
our deodorant they keep their
ingredients less bare naked man the
ingredients you understand like coconut
oil shea butter and baking soda that's
right it's vegan you can eat this [ __ ]
don't but you could let's say we're
trapped like Tom Hanks with Wilson on a
desert island and you got some native
floating in the water pick it up you
could eat it
but in that situation other than that
eat food kids always eat food native
deodorant checks a lot of boxes man
72-hour odor protection naturally
derived ingredients and a smooth
residue free application native also
offers a variety of scents with new and
limited edition uh smells and scents
being released all the time when you use
native you're gonna smell amazing all
day long thanks to their long lasting
scents want to smell spicy and woodsy
we're clean and fresh native has a scent
option for everyone man they even got
Christmas sets holiday sets limited
edition cabin collection of warm cider
and cinnamon cashmere and Rain toasted
marshmallow and vanilla Wildwood and
cardamom
which set did you receive and what did
you like about you know what I've got I
got the cinnamon and it was nice it made
me think of good times for a chain as
other Smiths have said I got that I got
the vanilla cookie
oh I've had that before [ __ ] it's
amazing you smell he literally legit
smells like cookies
so good I love the native products man I
was I was shopping the other day and I
actually bought uh [ __ ] native body
wash it was there in the store I was
like you know what they're always
[ __ ] helping me out let me help them
out and as I reached for it someone else
reached for it I looked up you know who
that was
Robert Downey Jr Barack Obama
it was a fellow new jerseyan who was
just like you too I was like [ __ ] yeah
this [ __ ] smells good I want to smell
like cookies
Bruce Springsteen it was that's right
the government himself Bruce Springsteen
it was Springsteen Bon Jovi the hybrid
pop Cult of pop music monster that lives
in New Jersey
um
you want this [ __ ] you want native all
over your face neck and chest all over
your body man what are you waiting for
smell and feel fresh all day long with
Native I love native man get 20 off your
first order by going to nativedeo.com
Fatman or use the promo code Fatman to
check out that's nativedeo.com Fatman or
use the promo code Fatman all one word
at checkout for 20 off your first order
we thanked good Folks at Native uh for
still sponsoring this show after all
this time this let's be honest kids this
show is mid
at best
a native always goes for Peak
and the fact that they're advertising on
a mid-show
that's that you know what that's called
charity we thank native for their
charity
yeah we are Peak mid
we are peaked
that's our next t-shirt never mind
Jeff's kiss not man beyond Peak mid
or mid peak people are so confused
um okay
we got to get to the questions and
that's where plant man comes in handy
man but before that happens I'm going to
remind you New Year's Eve you want to
spend it in New Jersey with me at
smodcast Castle Cinemas uh a uh New
Year's evening with Kevin Smith look at
that right there look at me with a mic
in my hand and my natural habitat you
know stuck in the stage like [ __ ]
Darth Maul waiting for those [ __ ]
electric doors to open and [ __ ] like
that uh come out and spend New Year's
Eve with me tickle tick tickles tickles
Galore tickets at
smodcastcinemas.com don't get just as
weird as you want it to it's bigger time
it's gonna be [ __ ] Peak mid
baby
uh speaking of peak mid oh bath man
there is
um we asked Batman to bring us questions
and whatnot he'll do that in a second
but sounds like he's got something on
his mind yeah I'm gonna well I was gonna
sell but it sold out
um so I am if you happen to be
going to the Walt Disney Concert Hall
Tuesday Wednesday or Thursday or you
want what's going on there I'm hosting
the pre-home alone
screening party with trivia and an ugly
sweater contest and scum and villainy
will be doing free wine tasting
of Skywalker lines so
if you if you're like I always wanted to
taste those Skywalker wines but they're
too expensive to buy by the bottle at
scum and villainy
get a ticket to go see home alone you
can answer some trivia we're giving away
prizes and uh you can sample some some
of Skywalker's best courtesy of scum and
villainy uh next Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday during their uh Home Alone
winter festivities
it's home alone with a with an orchestra
so they take the music out of it so you
listen to the music live
at the Disney Concert Hall yeah in L.A a
Geary place
that was an Iron Man
uh yes yeah okay so if you're on the
west coast you could do that but kids
are you on the East Coast because this
Saturday we're also showing Home Alone
for free
on Saturday come watch the movie for
nothing
um it's in celebration of um
a gentleman whose Name Escapes me right
now uh maybe somebody will pop up a chat
tell me uh but he's come to the theater
all the time and his wife he passed away
so his wife rents the theater out to
have a screening in his honor every year
isn't that sweet they're a big Christmas
it's great
yeah so we may not have a [ __ ] live
Orchestra you show off
but at smog Castle Cinemas we do it with
heart
it's my castle Cinemas the Heart is King
the lungs are queen and
the Jacks are your dick I guess I don't
know I haven't gotten that
the balls of the courts yes too yeah
uh okay Banff man
hit us with some questions uh first
question from Braden gosy our Goss uh do
you have a favorite Christmas memory
and if you had to spend the holidays
with any comic character who would it be
hmm wow
favorite Christmas memory
I mean I got so many
uh here's a general one it's not
specific but when I was growing up we
never had a real tree and this is not a
story about how sad that was this is a
story about how
whenever I think of Christmas I don't
think of real trees I think of uh this
this big box that would come down out of
the attic you know [ __ ] him once a year
and [ __ ] what a big celebration it was
you got to remember we didn't have cable
we didn't have [ __ ] the internet you
know life was real mid kids so
taking the tree down from the attic and
then putting it up once a year was like
[ __ ] huge big event
and uh archery got assembled it was like
three [ __ ] sticks rods that went into
each other with holes you know angled in
around the sides and then these wire
branches with fake you know dialed
valves on them and stuff and you color
code it to make sure you put the right
ones in the right holes you grew up in
the same era as I did Mr Martin
they were color-coded at the ends and
the little holes were also color coded
so you knew where to put them so I grew
up with a fake Christmas tree every year
but my mom at one point because we were
poor family and she hates when I say
that but it's true
um we were low she likes to say like we
were lower lower lower middle class but
we were just you know we report so
post Christmas one year
I guess you know some places are doing
blowout sales and [ __ ] like that
my mom gets this
Christmas tree holder
that's a base right they put your tree
into
but this [ __ ] you plug it into
the wall and you step on a clicker and
it slowly rotates what and so the tree
slowly rotated in my living room
and you know had the lights on it and
the lights would blink and [ __ ]
and I have very Serene memories of my
childhood like being in the living room
with all the lights off except for the
Christmas tree lights as this thing
you know did the slow
360 and you got to see every ornament
and every side of the tree and
you know I was just young enough and
again there were no [ __ ] distractions
like cable or the internet where
watching the ornaments go by and looking
at each one and remembering where they
came from or wondering where they came
from was enough to like you know capture
one's imagination for an evening and
stuff it was either that or watch Mash
reruns you know because we didn't have
cable yet so sometimes I just watch the
[ __ ] tree and think about the future
and so whenever I see
a Christmas tree first thing I look for
is to see if it's slowly turning and
they never do
um I haven't seen that any place else
I'm not saying it don't exist anymore
I'm sure somebody has a slowly rotating
Christmas tree stand
um but you know for the last 20 plus
years or whatever
um more than that ever since I've been
married we've been getting live you know
real Christmas trees Jennifer's big real
Christmas tree fan
so you can't put a real Christmas tree
in a [ __ ] spinning base even if one
exists but the hum of it is a very
particular noise
that like I'll remember for the rest of
my life it's just
as this thing slowly [ __ ] rotated for
a good 10 15 years of my life
every Christmas I I looked forward to
that moment when like Mom and Dad went
to bed
nobody else was around and I could just
be in the living room with the Christmas
tree and the lights buggy probably so I
could jerk off Mark let's be honest I
was a little bit lad
and who don't want to jerk off around
the Christmas tree
um but I was always a very uh nostalgic
sentimental kid and so I feel
like I used to sit there and think about
the future and um it's you know now
we're living in it that same future I
used to think about so not a very
specific locked in memory of Christmas
but a very Christmas oriented memory
that spans uh many years in my life as
for which
comic book character I'd like to spend
Christmas with
um
you know I'm gonna go pithy and say uh
the Human Torch
because I now that I've I'm not bragging
but I've lost weight and I'm on blood
thinners post heart attack
I'm always cold constantly cold
and you know I don't know if you know
this or not Mark but I'm on the East
Coast for a minute and [ __ ] it's cold
out here like I I miss my California
warmth and [ __ ] so
Christmas generally happens in a chilly
time of year
I'm gonna say I'd like to be around
Johnny Storm because I'd constantly be
like fighting on and I'd make him light
on fire and [ __ ]
he's like stop saying it I'm not on
Alexa
like just let me say it
no way flame on
do it flame yeah flame low
and then I tuned
midflake yeah
midflame it's such a mid flame God even
the flameth mid come on John
you could be better than this it's
Johnny
uh what about you what's your Christmas
memory
um
you know I I have a few from when I was
a kid which you know like they're
they were all kind of of a piece my
parents were not particularly
um rigid with with when the Christmas
festivities could begin
we were always Christmas Day people
weren't Christmas Eve people
um but it somehow got to the point where
as long as it had kicked over to
midnight 1201 meant to Christmas and so
if we were up we could then open [ __ ]
and so my brother and I my younger
brother and I a couple of years would
like wake up at 2 A.M and go downstairs
and just have a [ __ ] backing out
opening presents playing with [ __ ] and
then we'd wipe ourselves out and just
fall asleep surrounded by the chaos of
Christmas and our parents would find us
under the tree
just sleeping
um but I think My Favorite Christmas
Memories when my kids were like six and
four
um and that is about the time especially
when my son was like four and he could
not have been more excited for [ __ ]
Christmas
and so just that unbridled enthusiasm to
get to go down the stairs and see what
Santa brought it
um I've never seen anybody happier than
that moment of like not even grounding
the stairs to see the tree or just
standing at the top of the stairs
waiting to go down
um and so I'll just always remember that
level of nothing bad can happen now
because it's Christmas it's Christmas
morning and whatever's downstairs will
be of my favorite thing ever and it was
and and that that that kind of innocent
optimism
always kind of sticks with me
um even though now you think you still
have that
does he still have it no
no I mean because you still have
innocent optimism as a writer
um
yeah I hope so
you know I mean because the hope is that
you will write a thing that surprises
you you'll write a thing that you didn't
see coming you'll write a thing that
moves you in a way you couldn't have
anticipated like so then you get to open
a present that you wrapped for yourself
and that you didn't know what was going
to be inside
you know and I think that that that's
the the high that we kind of Chase all
the time
is the can I tell myself a story that
I'm that I'm surprised by because we're
our first readers me and Mark working on
a thing I talked about earlier this uh
writing some scripts for this series and
um Mark uh did some yesterday we had a
writer's Summit
um which is you know basically just sit
around and go like what if it was this
what if we did this oh and just putting
clothes on this [ __ ] thing and Mark
did a thing that made me cry and right
then and there I mean people are like so
and it must have been a day of the week
with high in it but yes of course but in
a writing session that's [ __ ] gold
because like you know I I know how to I
see the strings I know how the sausage
is made and I know how manipulative all
this [ __ ] is so I should not be
susceptible to mark saying a thing that
then makes me go
you know and [ __ ] choke up and go
wet-eyed and [ __ ] but Mark had a moment
for the final episode of this thing
we're working on that was just
it was made me so emotional right then I
welled up and I was like that
[ __ ] plays and it's right at the end
too so it helps to stick the landing
um that was not mid that was [ __ ]
Peak kids we try for Peak we settle from
it
what's that Marvel character would you
want a sport what character would you
want to spend Christmas with doesn't
have to be Marvel and I should point out
somebody in chat was like
hey since when is yelling flame on turn
on the Human Torch like it's not that
was my little comedy bit by the way
Human Torch not real so
none of it is
um I think the character who would make
the most fun Christmas would be Thor
I think Thor likes a [ __ ] party
someone likes a big table full of food
on it Thor has some goddamn stories some
of which probably involve reindeer
actual reindeer
um
I feel like if you were throwing a party
Thor's your goddamn guy
um honestly like every answer could be
you know what it'll be funny if Thor was
here
and that like sad modern Thor from Thor
the Dark World I mean like good time
Thor like all my shit's dealt with
everything's resolved my daddy issues
are in the basement like let's just get
some [ __ ] hell and I'll tell you some
stories about the time Loki hit a
[ __ ] snake under the tree
and to think about uh he knows how to
hate Stakes
it bit me
I like it bathman you got any uh
response to this bamf uh I've got I've
got a couple
uh I also did not grow up of means
and uh one of the things I loved every
year was waiting for Charlie Brown
Christmas to come on like is it coming
on yet is it like asking my parents
every day uh when like the frosty when
the cartoons were gonna come on uh but
my favorite Christmas ever and we
spent all the money and sprung for a
video camera and I still have it which
is
I got this which is green screening out
which is the Kenner Hall of Justice toy
uh I got that and the Ewok village in
this same year
I love that I was too old for it and too
poor but [ __ ] I always wanted that
wow you got that and the and the Ewok
village yeah and that was I was like
four years old and it was like
I I mean it's 38 years 38 Christmases
later and that is still the greatest
morning of my entire well greatest
morning of my life child you [ __ ] she
was born in the afternoon so that's the
greatest afternoon
uh yeah those were my two uh if I had to
spend Christmas with a comic character
there was an episode towards at some
point in the X-Men animated series
amorlox Christmas I would invite the
morlocks over
spend it with them
nice look at you well done all right
what's our next question
uh okay
uh let's do
um Digital Play Harrison's head his kid
is mid
[Laughter]
night okay your kid is midday
uh digital puppets uh if you could go
back and show your 10 year old self any
movie available in 2022 which movie
would you pick and why
I mean I do that all the time I am my 10
year old self so again when I watch a
movie
that's what's that's who's saying it um
I mean honestly like I might
I would probably show that I'd probably
show that kid end game
to be like this is what you have to stay
alive for I know I should show them one
of my own movies to be like this is what
you do but I would love to show yeah
maybe I should show him clerks three
and work this into an ad for clerks
three now on home video
um
yeah I'd probably show them Clark's
three to be like oh my god look what you
do one day
but then I'd be like I'd show them like
the first 10 minutes and then I'd be
like you know what let's watch end game
instead and then I'd show them end game
and be like look at this [ __ ]
do it man
if you can't man okay
what the future just like live you must
stay alive I will find you that's what I
tell them
he'd be so [ __ ] impressed by that
[ __ ] like when they all when they all
do the [ __ ] challenge of the Super
Friends run at each other which we now
have a [ __ ] really good chance
of replicating with James Gunn in charge
over at DC man
you know that somewhere they're having a
conversation going well we have to
eventually give them the what people
want to call the Civil War shot but like
what will be the challenge of the Super
Friends shots they run at each other oh
that's what I want to live for now Mark
we'll see that within the next five
years I'm predicting
so that gives me five years to stay
alive to see the live action version of
that I remember being a kid watching
that show watching challenge with the
Super Friends and like look at them all
running each other and then when they
did it in Civil War it was like oh my
God the russos and [ __ ] Kevin Foggy
Rock but now we got a chance to do the
actual thing with the actual DC
characters
and I bet you James Gunn gets us there I
have faith in James Gunn
um wait where were we
uh movie you would want to show your 10
year old self the Justice League of
America versus the Legion of Doom is
that Ted Knight doing the voiceover it
certainly sounds lucky
challenge of the Super Friends
um I feel like mine is a little bit of a
cheat
um because I feel like I'd want to show
myself Lord of the Rings
um
don't bore your [ __ ] childhood self
and tell you how long the future is the
future goes on for like nine hours kid
it's gonna have the future never ends
kid the future's A Long Walk Futures
Future's pretty mid
um I feel like it's [ __ ] yeah I mean
there's something about the 10 year old
me who loved kind of fantasy seeing what
that could look like for real and like
the best version of that
um
also maybe Peter Jackson's King Kong you
know because I also growing up in the in
the 70s
yeah
except [ __ ] I didn't expect that I
honestly expected you to make a pass at
me before I expected you to reference
King Kong in any conversation let alone
like the what do you want to show young
Mark wow did you like it that much
um I love when I was a kid I loved King
Kong because I love the 78 version which
you know had the amazing poster of Kong
straddling both towers of the of the of
the world yeah of course brilliant you
know and so that that that version of
that movie is the version that I sort of
as a kid even as an adult was like oh
yeah this is [ __ ] great I love this
there's no bad part of this at all
um but
that Peter Jackson again it's the the
thing you liked as a kid realized within
an inch of its capabilities
so like you love fantasy the kid let me
show you the best fantasy movie ever you
love King Kong as a kid who's the best
King Kong movie ever
um
you know I don't know if black panther
would have meant anything to that Cube
um
you know the way that it meant something
to an older person
um maybe it you know especially if
that's the only thing I got to see when
I was 10 and there wouldn't be another
black superhero for another 40 [ __ ]
years
like that's that's almost like water in
the desert as opposed to uh to fuel for
the fire
um
but yeah I mean but it's also like when
I was 10
I saw Raiders for the first time because
Raiders was out you know like I was
already beginning to see the movies that
would inspire me that you know I'm still
not sure that to this day I've seen
better movies than Empire than Raiders
Than You Know The Last Starfighter in 82
like
we were about to hit a golden age of
genre movies
um but just to show a kid like no guess
where we're going here's what's possible
um I think would be kind of great
Daniel Martin and chat just put up one
of my favorite [ __ ] lines of the
Marvel movie of all time nobody starmark
built this in a cave
Jeff Bridges don't get enough credit for
that [ __ ] absolute perfect [ __ ]
delivery
um okay bath man
um
not a good one I think I was 10 in like
1990 1991
kids and honestly any of the Star Wars
even the ones I don't like any of the
Marvel any of the stuff that would have
just been like
kind of like your time's coming like get
you're gonna get [ __ ] on now but the
stuff you like will be the most popular
uh I think
I think any of it would have left an
impression
fair enough
fair enough
all right last question uh third
question D month two uh we talked about
meet the Fable mints quite a bit uh yeah
so if we got to meet the Fable men if
Spielberg was on fat man what is your
first question we ask
um
first we'd blown for like a good 20
minutes that's not a question to be
found yeah it really it would just be
like you you Chris Farley it for a while
remember that time remember that time
you made Jaws that was awesome
um
I uh yeah I would say I would thank him
uh we had recently um we had this mod
Castle Film Festival
from November 30th to December 4th and
it was absolutely [ __ ] wonderful
Ernie did such a great job and uh being
surrounded by all those filmmakers we
had Awards it was just [ __ ] it really
reinvigorated my spirit creative spirit
and stuff we'll do it again and again it
will become an annual event but in any
event on Sunday I did some panels at The
Originals mod Castle the small Podcast
Theater now we're one town over at
Atlantic Highlands with a mult with a
multiplex on First Avenue
um and uh while I was doing the panels
we had uh I was talking to the folks
from decentralized pictures who we work
with and Roman uh Coppola Coppola was uh
zooming in
and him and his dad are working on
megalopolis right now you know Francis
Ford Coppola is back directing
and he was talking about since we were
talking about like uh blockchain
technology he was talking about how
technology is always kind of pushed
forward but in filmmaking
and he's like you know I don't want to
tube my father's horn but like
like Jerry Lewis invented video assist
you know which is when you're you're the
monitor that sees what the camera sees
so that he could go be in front of the
camera and then when the take was over
he would go and watch his take rather
than waiting days for the film to be
developed waiting for dailies or
something
so I guess Francis Ford Coppola went to
visit
Jerry Lewis or something like that and
saw it in action
and was like you know that's a like a
good [ __ ] idea
and he brought it to his next movie
which was one from the heart
and
normalized the video assist system which
is now every everywhere you don't go to
a set and there's not a video assist
this is a piece of technology Mark that
has made what I do for a living possible
I live and die by video assist because
oftentimes I'm in the movies that I make
and so the same thing like you want to
shoot it and then watch it and then go
improve it in another take
and this [ __ ] like the trickle-down
of that guy going to one guy's set and
being like oh yeah that makes sense I'm
gonna bring it and then he brings it and
then makes it the standard
a standard that when I enter the
business by time I'm like I want to make
a movie it is a [ __ ] standard we
didn't get to use one on clerks because
we had no money but Mallrats forward
it's been a big part of my existence
fact that like
that generation
of filmmakers made
my life even possible my art even
possible
so Steven Spielberg
you know inarguably
um Jaws is clearly an influential film
for me not only did it keep me out of
the water
um for my entire [ __ ] life and [ __ ]
which probably saved my [ __ ] life
because I didn't enter the food chain
but there's a moment to meet the
fablemans where his mom is talking about
how he's trying to
capture the moment that he saw in the
theater he's trying to control the
moment he's trying to control what he
saw uh so he's you know in this case so
he's not scared of what he saw
this horrific image of like you know a
train crash and [ __ ]
um when I was a kid
um when I was a Youngster Jaws played on
the [ __ ] TV for the first time on ABC
and the voice of was his name Percy
Rodriguez was like a now the conclusion
of Jaws
um
when it played I whipped out my tape
recorder and I recorded the thing so I
could listen to it over and over and
over again
now you know Jaws is a wonderful
sonorous listen because there's a lot of
section of just John Williams score that
forces you to use your imagination if
you're listening to an audio cassette of
it
but it's also a great way to learn how
to write dialogue because there's a
large section of that movie where people
talk to each other like human beings or
monologue and tell large stories about
boats that go down and [ __ ] sharks
that eat people so
listening to it over and over again when
I watch that scene and in the fablemens
where she's like he's trying to control
it you know I weld up instantly because
I was like I know I know that feeling I
know that moment where it's just like
you're so fascinated and scared by and
horrified of but in love with something
that you
you obsessively interact with it you
know and we're talking about now it's
easy to do that right thanks to the
internet but this was at a time when it
was impossible well not impossible but
much much harder to recapture a moment
um I thought my life was hard because
like I man they didn't [ __ ] invent
the VCR until like the early 80s [ __ ]
Spielberg comes of age in a time where
like his mother has to buy him a movie
camera so that he can recreate the
moment but in doing so cast the die
that sets his entire [ __ ] life so I
think
if I were to ask him a question
my first question after the all the
gushing
um would be
clearly your parents divorce
um has impacted your life and your art
um if you could
have them never split up and hence never
be
Stephen Spielberg
but go back to like you know a happy
childhood before your family breaks up
which clearly affected it
would you give it all up
to be that kid instead of this kid
and you'd be like why am I doing this
podcast I thought we were gonna [ __ ]
talk about the [ __ ] how cute the
fablements is why are you going so deep
so fast
uh what about you mark what are you
asking
I mean
it's a it's
it's difficult because
you don't want to you don't want to ask
him the questions that he's already been
asked right like you just
you don't want to you don't want to be
that guy
and it's so easy to be that guy
um
but I kind of I mean there's two things
I'd want to ask him like
what's his favorite move not what he
thinks the best movie is I mean there's
there's empirical answers to like you
know Citizen Kane or you know The Man
Who Shot Liberty Valance or The
Godfather or whatever those those
answers that we all sort of receive as
cinematic wisdom like what's his
favorite
um as a dude who's lived in grieved
movies for you know the better part of
70 years
um what's the one that that he goes back
to what's his comfort mean
um and then from a technical
storytelling perspective it's the you
know what's what tool does he have no
interest in using
you know is he I mean CG is clearly not
it because he's he will happily Embrace
that but is there some
is there some shot is there some
Innovation is there some like Willie
shoot digital well like what is there is
there anything that's off limits for him
when it comes to making a film
um who or we could ask him a request oh
please make another Jaws
naturally
like think about how good Jaws is and
that is Steven Spielberg at the start of
his career
now I'm not saying remake Jaws but I'm
saying make another Jaws
and have him do it we've seen him do
sequels he's [ __ ] wicked good at it
sometimes so
I I would be like look you know I asked
you the serious question now here's my
request please make another [ __ ] Jaws
please please go back to those
characters please you know what [ __ ]
Richard Dreyfuss Dicky dreyf is still
alive please
[ __ ] one more Jaws where Richard
Dreyfus is like the old Salty Dog and
[ __ ] maybe he's lost a leg to a shark
somewhere
just so that he can limp and stuff
because Richard dreyf is kind of old
right
he's not a young cat anymore but they're
both still here make a Jaws thing please
Steven Spielberg that's what I'd say
yeah I mean I also wonder like does he
still get nervous
does he still like
on day one of a shoot like are you still
a little apprehensive like as a person
who's done it for as long as he's done
it like is there ever that feeling
of
you know just I don't know if I can pull
this one off like does being scared of
it in any way
factor into his process in making it
that's a good question
I'd have to guess I can't imagine you to
get scared anymore I'm sure he's like
yeah I mean literally this dude has been
doing this since he was a child
you know I've been doing it since I was
[ __ ] like 22. he's been doing it
since he was like five and now what 70
something like
you know over 50 years of her career I
got to imagine the dudes like
kind of like driving like I just know
how to do it
I I I I believe that that's possible but
I also believe like I've heard
interviews with like
it's not getting Bruce Springsteen it
was like yeah man sometimes there are
some shows where I'm just like is this
going to be the one like do I have it
today I'm not sure like Mom let's not
[ __ ] it up like but again you're Bruce
Springsteen you're Paul McCartney you're
you're a [ __ ] Mick Jagger like you've
been doing this longer than I've been
alive is there ever does that
energy still remain and if so is that
necessary for you
Victor Cotto and chat says Jaws was for
Mid cucks
I've seen a lot of things written on the
internet but I know that ain't true
um JC Banff man Banff uh I'd ask ask him
if he really killed that dinosaur the
way the internet says he did
did you guys see that
so this photo
that one famous Jurassic Park photo
yeah they posted that online like
five or six years ago and he got he got
attacked for killing an endangered
species
no there's an LA Times article about it
and stuff it's wild
so
I would everybody always asks some of
these like very heartfelt questions like
you guys I'd ask him like so did you
actually kill a dinosaur or no
just try to break the ice or break the
ice right there
people are [ __ ] strange man
like
that's
and and yet
that's the same medium that allowed
people to [ __ ] accuse Steven
Spielberg of killing a dinosaur
is the same medium that
gave us mid
giveth and it take it it really does
there's nothing wrong with the Internet
it's a functioning exactly as it should
I guess
uh there it is kids uh what does this
say Matt Lewis says I love Kevin in this
show I've seen pretty much all of them
and I've seen him live several times but
I have to say the constant crying is
getting close to
he's not did I [ __ ] cry on this show
oh you cried talking about fablements
earlier
barely like when I cry you'll know yeah
barely
[ __ ] saying that Kevin Smith cries a
lot is so [ __ ] mid there I said it
it's kind of like you're it's kind of
like your Picard maneuver
it truly is some guys pull their shirt
down when they [ __ ] other guys just get
emotional wear their heart on their
sleeves I'm gonna say it one more time
for the cheap seats I had a heart attack
a few years ago and I'm in a lot of
[ __ ] drugs to keep me alive and that
might have something to do with why I'm
so much so maybe not
I knew me as a young kid I was a bit of
a [ __ ] then too so there it is but
being this [ __ ] little boy this cuck if
you will has made me a multi milk yeah
there I said it two wolves inside of
every person one of them tugs that shuts
down when they [ __ ] the other one cries
and almost everything
both wolves my friend it's exactly
uh kids did you ever uh think we'd uh
finish this show
[ __ ] no way it started like 23 hours
ago
and finally we've reached a conclusion
uh Kevin's like hey does anybody have a
heart out today it's like nope oh that's
testing truly
um yeah man it's uh it's good times good
times for a change as another Smith once
said
um if you had a good time kids
thank uh Banff man who made things
happen for you me and Mark without bam
fam we're just two dudes staring at a
computer going how do we do it what do
we do Hello computer
okay sounds good computer
um how quaint uh Batman came in and then
I guess because we weren't ready to
handle the floor you [ __ ] up
man I I waved goodbye it's like say
goodbye
my 12 fans goodbye 12 fans I'll be
hosting trivia in
two hours and 45 minutes at scum and
villainy if anybody's in La wants to say
hi yeah right you're doing a live event
that's true how many people you get for
trivia
uh 100 a night ish
I want 100 people to come to trivia
smodcast who wants to run my trivia
nights I should uh you know what I
should do you should do it I'll just
send you my questions every week you
could do it on Wednesday or Thursday
nights
done and done we could actually even
stream it
it's all nerdy stuff we totally should
if you get that liquor license we should
do that because
even without a liquor license I'm
stealing your [ __ ] and I'll credit you
I'll call the scum and villainy [ __ ]
pub quiz and [ __ ] but like that'll be a
nice placeholder until I get a liquor
license and then you come out and build
a [ __ ] scum and villainy inside Smart
Guys you incept podcast we shove scum
Mobility up the ass of smodcast oh man
and make a bait like this uh this week
we have an audio round that's what's the
connection so I'm gonna play nine
different Snippets of songs and you have
to tell me who what the name of the song
is and then at the end they're all
connected in some way
uh we have a same last name category
and we have a Spider-Man category so far
so same last name would be like
uh
Indiana Jones and the guy Steven
Spielberg talks to at the end of
fablement and B Harrison and John Ford
so that's like the type of question
that's good I'll take those questions
especially if they're free uh
slice 9900 on uh and chat says Kevin
Smith's last good movie was clerks too
um what was your last good movie none
right shut the [ __ ] up but it's a nice
reminder the clerk's three is now on
home video ladies and gentlemen Blu-ray
and DVD sold so many units and [ __ ] uh
Lions gave very happy with us I'm very
happy because the movie was received
incredibly well we finished the clerk's
convenience tour clerks three
convenience Tour on December 6th out in
Hartford Connecticut man 52 shows thank
you to everybody who joined us on the
tour man
um I put up my latest Instagram as me
taking pictures with all the VIPs Josh
Roush put together a super cut
and it's pretty impressive uh that tour
was everything that I dreamed it would
be plus more and that had everything to
do with people that showed up so thank
you
so much that tour nothing mid about it
my friends all Peak as far as I was
concerned
um just like this show right here man
all Peak and that's because of the guy
who sits
over there oh I got it right uh give it
up for marvelous Mark Bernard and
everybody
array
Good Times
good time indeed
um okay
kids one more time for the cheap seats
if you have nothing to do on New Year's
Eve
come this modcastle hang out with me
bring in the New Year a New Year's
evening
with Kevin Smith that's right man
tickets available right now at
smodcastlecinemas.com uh we back next
week I think we have to do a show next
week
that's great kids I was gonna wear a
Christmas hat tonight but I was like
wait we're gonna do this again next week
I'm Gonna Save the Christmas hat so I
got something to build too Christmas hat
two weeks before Christmas very mid one
week before Christmas Peak
one more time
um and here at uh fat man beyond the mid
is King
the peak is Queen
[ __ ] cringes
the Ace of [ __ ] Hearts I don't know
my card that's okay
uh kids there it is man
uh boy do we have a good time
as always always nothing better than
talking about geeky [ __ ] and having
total strangers be like you're wrong
it's like all right fantastic
um thank you for hanging out with us
this evening
um we've had a blast I've had a blast I
can't speak for Mark but I can read them
and I can tell that he had a good good
ass time
look at him he wears his heart on his
sleeve this kid this kid I love this
although I blew out my ring light
literally to the point where there was
like I smelled smoke
yeah run run Hall of Justice you're
right there with all of Justice somebody
will come out and say you're an Aquaman
put that [ __ ] out he's like I inog with
him anymore now I'm Lobo that's not my
power you mean you don't have power over
water no well then why the [ __ ] don't
they call you Aquaman
all right kids
there it is we hate to end the show but
we gotta [ __ ]
and the show
there's your video
fat man beyond man we'll be back next
week with more show
for now
this is all the show you're gonna get
uh for fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith
and I'm Mark Bernardi tune in next time
[ __ ] same that time same fat channels
modcast.com or tube.com Kevin Smith
Jeff's kiss my friends
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]